Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Thomas.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik folge einhundertsechsundsiebzig ohne Tim dafür mit Thomas Lohninger, der ja schon oft bei uns zu Gast war und äh über den ich mich auch heute,
wieder freue.
Wie immer schön hier zu sein.
Was hat dich hierher äh äh verschleppt? Kann man äh kann man darüber sprechen oder bist du wieder in geheimer äh lobbyistischer Mission.
Ganz, ganz öffentliche Edri, äh European Disco Rights, unser Dachverband in Brüssel hat seine Generalversammlung dieses Wochenende in Berlin und da habe ich mich gerade ein bisschen weggestohlen, um diese Sendung zu machen.
Wunderbar. Dann können wir ja nur ganz kurz, du hast die letzte Sendung ja auch schon gehört, wie ich gehört habe.
Ja, ich äh du, du, du du nutzt deine Zeit sehr gut, weil diese Reflektion über
Big Data und künstliche Intelligenz ähm das ist genau die Art von Gedanken, die ich mir auch gerne machen würde, aber zu denen ich nicht komme in dem ganzen Tagesgeschäft, aber das ist eigentlich das, womit wir uns jetzt beschäftigen sollten, bevor es uns überrollt.
Bahn fahren, ich mach das immer beim Bahnfahren. Dann denk ich darüber nach.
Dann denke ich darüber nach. Ich bin viel Bahn gefahren in letzter Zeit.
Ja, ich auch.
Na, es gab natürlich, also es gab Feedback und ich muss mal wieder sagen, wir hatten, sie hat sich Logbuchnetzkritik wieder äh als äh äh Quell des Diskurses äh bewiesen, ja, ordentliche Kommentare ausformuliert ähm
wenige Angriffe, nein, gar keine. Äh das ist, es scheint echt zu scheint noch so zu funktionieren da mit dem mit dem mit der Debatte im Internet
Ähm Sebastian hat angemerkt, dass äh autonomer aufgrund autonome Fahrzeuge aufgrund der Notwendigkeit halten zu können, bevor etwas passiert. Ähm.
Vor allem dazu führen werden, dass der Autoverkehr in bewohnten Gegenden, wo irgendwie auch Menschen rumrennen, äh viel, viel langsamer wird. Ähm dass,
Davon ist auszugehen, das ist aber kein glaube ich nicht, dass das große Problem ist. Die Autos werden sich langsamer bewegen,
aber die werden eine bessere Flusskontrolle haben. Das heißt, du hast im Prinzip äh also wenn du heute meinst, du du fährst in einer bewohnten Gegend schnell, dann kommst du ja nicht schneller an,
Du bremst halt nur mehr, du verkaufst, du verschwendest halt mehr,
mehr Energie und fährst an jeder Ampel an ohne Stopps und sowas. Und ich würde äh denken, so ein voll so eine möglichst gut automatisierte äh Autoverkehr würde sich den der Bewegung von Zügen annähern. Das heißt, die Autos fahren alle langsam,
kommst trotzdem schneller an und hättest im Prinzip den Effekt, den du heute mit einem Fahrrad hast,
Weil wenn ich irgendwie hier in Berlin äh gegen ein Auto antrete auf eine Distanz von sagen wir mal sechs bis acht Kilometer gewinne ich.
Einfach, weil ich das Auto die gleichen Ampeln hat wie ich,
ist es bei jeder Ampel einhole und ab und zu ähm also es gab ja mal zum Beispiel so Ideen, dass ich das mir unterstellt wurde, ich würde rote Ampeln jetzt
in einigen Fällen hätte ich die vielleicht großzügig ausgelegt als Empfehlung oder so, ja? Und jetzt das wäre jetzt ja nur eine weitere.
Ähm
Also eben ein weiterer Optimierungsfaktor, dass du deine Autos halt du willst halt nicht, dass die andauernd anhalten. Willst du sowieso nicht. Das ist übrigens hier der Spritschwandel, ne, oder oder Strom an seinem äh Elektroauto Elektroautos bremsen eh von alleine. Ähm also bremse ja über den Generator, aber wer sprit sparen will, so fahren, dass man nicht bremsen muss.
Bremsen ist Energie, die der Motor erzeugt hat, die du in Wärme umwandelst und das wird's eigentlich nicht. Das heißt, du willst auch, dass deine das deine Fahrzeuge einfach möglichst nicht anhalten müssen. Und ich würde davon ausgehen, dass man
die Flusskontrolle so macht, dann fahren die halt alle langsam, aber du kommst trotzdem genauso zügig an.
Das heißt, irgendwann haben wir in der Zukunft nur noch geräuschlose Elektroautos, die über die Straßen gleiten.
In gleichmäßiger Geschwindigkeit ja und alles ist gut.
Dann wurde noch angemerkt von Rotwild, dass wir ein,
Einen Vortrag dazu hatten beim dreiunddreißig äh beim zweiunddreißig C drei. Ich bin schon sehr in den Vorbereitungen,
How Ergoriven, my Zoom Control Hour lives ähm und da wurde äh bemängelt, dass ich den nicht äh, dass ich den nicht empfohlen habe, ja, habe ich vergessen. Äh danke für den Hinweis.
An der Stelle kann ich auch nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen, dass diese Themen, dieses Thema Algorithmen, Ethik
Ja tatsächlich so ein bisschen eine Rolle gespielt hat beim zweiunddreißig C drei ähm in der medialen Berichterstattung, da gab's so ein Interview.
Äh was ich da gegeben habe ähm mit dem NDR äh das wurde für verschiedene äh Veröffentlichungen genutzt. Ich glaube, das war irgendwie dann auch in Tagesthemen oder so, aber,
da gibt's 'n Ausschnitt auf auf NDR DE unter der Sendung,
dass das ganze Interview, wo ich nämlich eigentlich mich dazu äußere und sage, also diese äh das Ding steht unter dem äh transparent ähm
revidierbar. Es ist halt, wo ich gesagt habe, okay, wenn wenn wir unser Leben den Algorithmen unterwerfen.
Ähm dann müssen diese Algorithmen oder die Entscheidungen, die die Algorithmen treffen, nachvollziehbar, transparent und revidierbar sein, u.
Quasi sicherzustellen, dass wir äh da irgendwie in der Zukunft äh,
akzeptable äh Umstände für uns Menschen finden. Ähm das kann man sich da gerne nochmal anschauen, aber natürlich insbesondere ist der äh Vortrag, der vor uns sehr highto you nu Boss. Ähm.
Dann gab's noch in den Kommentaren weite äh ausführliche Debatten darüber, ob das Trolli-Problem, das nämlich also das Trolli-Problem ist, dieses dieses ähm.
Ich glaube, das kommt von den also das ist dieses dieses Erstsemester Philosophie-Dilemma. Äh der, der, der, der, der Wagon, rast den.
Rast auf den Bahnhof zu und an den einen in das eine an die eine an das eine ähm
Gleis ist irgendwie eine Oma äh gefesselt und an die anderen, da stehen zehn Leute und du bist an der Weiche, ne? Das ist das Trolli-Problem. Wo dann eben gesagt wird, ja, ne, wenn du nicht handelst, ähm dann,
siehst du zu, wie zehn wie zehn Menschen sterben, obwohl du eigentlich das auf eine Person hättest reduzieren können und,
ne, denn dann gibt's ja so diese ethische Problematik, ne? Du musst morgen um äh du musst irgendwie die C, du musst die eine Person ermorden, um die
anderen Szenen zu retten und dann gibt's hier auch so dieses ganze Dilemma, es wurde ja dann auch in den Kommentaren angeführt mit den mit dem Abschießen von entführten Flugzeugen
Was ja quasi so eine eine großes Thema äh war in Deutschland und auch immer noch ist, weil's gerade diese Theaterinszenierung von,
Ferdinand von Schirach gibt, Terror, wo es im Prinzip darum geht, also es Szenario ist ein Bundeswehrkampfpilot.
Ne, Abfangjäger äh begleitet, ein entführtes Flugzeug, dieses entführte Flugzeug will, hat das erklärte Ziel in so ein Fußballstadion zu fliegen.
Die die Rechtslage ist, äh dass die das nicht abschießen dürfen. Ja und der äh die.
Dann gibt's halt irgendwie einen Prozess darüber, dass dieser Kampfpilot das doch macht,
und das seine generelle ihm irgendwie quasi bestimmte Informationen geben oder nicht geben oder zum Beispiel nicht das Stadion räumen, unsere lange lange Debatte, ich fand das Theaterstück wirklich fürchterlich, weil ich in meinem Leben einfach,
kein Bock mehr auf Trolli-Probleme habe und meine These ist, äh wir haben zweihundert Jahre Eisenbahnbetrieb als Menschheit hinter uns und das volle Problem ist kein einziges Mal aufgetreten.
Genau das sehe ich halt für autonome Fahrzeuge ebenso. Äh aber es gibt Leute, die sehen das anders und die möchten das, möchten das weiter machen. Ähm möchten diese Debatten führen
ähm können sie auch gerne tun. Ich will, es gibt ja keine Denkverbote. Bei Lokbuch-Netzwerkik, es gibt aber eine Auswahl dessen, was relevant ist. Und dessen, was ich für mich relevant halte. Und äh das halte ich für nicht relevant
Ähm,
Sebastian hat dann angemerkt, ja die Autos sind eh so gebaut, dass jede Entscheidung mit dem Ziel getroffen werden muss, jeden Schaden zu vermeiden und das heißt im Fall von einem Auto,
einfach stehen zu bleiben. Ja, das heißt, sie werden dich auch sagen oder die Autos werden einfach nicht in die Situation mehr kommen, dass sie äh ein Risiko haben. Da gibt's irgendwie so super geile äh geiles Phänomen irgendwie, habe ich sie immer geschildert bekommen, so ein.
Ähm äh ähm wenn du mit einem, wenn du ein Fahrrad mit mit ohne Freilauf hast, ne, kannst ja mit dem Fahrrad rückwärts fahren. Und das ermöglicht es dir auch auf der Stelle zu stehen.
Track Stand heißt das. Du stehst jetzt quasi hältst mit dem Fahrrad an und dadurch, dass du quasi mit dem mit dem Hinterrad nach vorne und nach hinten fahren kannst und dabei den Lenker ein bisschen schräg hältst, kannst du mit dem Fahrrad auf der Stelle stehen bleiben. Ähm Leute, die das nicht können.
Fahren gerne mal dann auf der Stelle vor und zurück. Ja und das sieht dann halt so ein bisschen Goofy aus, bis es dann halt irgendwann mal können. Und da war halt irgendwie jemand, der quasi so.
Autonomen Auto begegnet ist von Google und dann irgendwie angehalten hat und dadurch, dass er halt irgendwie sich dann immer vor und zurückbewegt hat, hat er dieses Auto mitgemacht.
Und kam halt nicht voran, weil es halt irgendwie das Auto halt gesagt hat, so, ja, nee, äh ich gehe jetzt irgendwie ähm ich mache jetzt hier nichts, ne?
Und da ist ein, ein Hindernis, was sich bewegt. Das ist übrigens genau noch das andere, was was wirklich problematisch wird oder wo dieses ganze autonome Fahren gerade seine Probleme hat. Äh ich meine, Spurhalten und so, das könnte ja schon längst.
Probleme haben, die mit sage ich mal klugem Regelbruch. Also ähm,
Grund, so zum Beispiel in das autonome Auto fährt durch Berlin, ja? Und dann hält aber hier ein Taxifahrer in der zweiten Reihe, an einer durchgezogenen Linie
Das heißt, die Verkehrsregelmäßig, also die verkehrsgerechte richtige Entscheidung wäre,
stehen zu bleiben und zu behupen, ja. Aber die Sinnvolle ist natürlich einfach zu gucken, wann keiner kommt,
vorbeizufahren und was weiß ich, die Bullen zu rufen, damit die den irgendwie ein Knöllchen geben oder so, ne? Ähm und da haben die Autos äh
Da haben die KI-Leute tatsächlich Probleme mit den Autos quasi sowas wie gesunden Menschenverstand beim Regelübertritt beizubringen, weil das natürlich echt ein Problem wäre, wenn dein Auto halt eine.
Regel verletzt und dadurch halt dann auch noch ein Unfall verursacht, ne? Deswegen also wird's halt konservativ sein und dein Auto fährt halt nicht immer die durchgezogene Linie, weil damit nicht.
Ich glaube, die Wende so eine Debatte haben, wo jeder Regelverstoß und jeder Unfall, der vom autonomen Auto ausgelöst wird, sofort enorme Öffentlichkeit bekommt und dadurch werden die Superpingulick auf alle Regeln achten. Was natürlich da bricht, wo andere das nicht tun.
Dann wird halt die Debatte sein, wer sind die besseren Autofahrer.
Da gibt's übrigens äh der der Kommentar von Pascal, der sagt, Linus, du sagst ja, dass Menschen im Zweifelsfall dann bessere äh Maschinen
Im Zweifelsfall dann bessere, weil präzisere Entscheidungen treffen. Diese Formulierung finde ich schwierig, weil ja niemand davon abgehalten wird, eine Psychopathen-KI zu bauen, die so,
Also die quasi.
So agieren, wie wenn sie allein, wenn alle so agieren würden, nicht funktioniert, aber ähm da alle anderen anders agieren, funktioniert's, ne? Also quasi eine Schmarotza KI gegen die anderen äh loslassen. Aber das ist inwiefern eine Zukunft.
Es wird ihr Arschloch äh die Arschlochknopf, den du drücken kannst, wenn du das Businesspaket gebraucht hast.
Genau, aber diese Psychopathen KI äh müsste halt gegen andere antreten und äh im Moment sieht sie eben danach aus, dass wir.
Wahrscheinlich nicht zwei KIs gegeneinander haben werden.
Die KIs werden klüger, dadurch, dass sie gegen sich selber spielen, aber nicht dadurch, dass wir irgendwie zwei haben, ne? Es wird halt nur einer sein. Na ja. Ähm.
Dann gab's noch irgendwie so ein klassischer, klassischer Kommentar von Max. Die Annahme, dass man mit Big Data alle Erkenntnisse über alle Personen hat, ist schlicht falsch. Ja, ist sie. Äh egal wie viele Mandaten man hat, es wird immer äh ein beies und Fehlentscheidungen geben
Ja, das war aber auch mein Argument. Das es Fehlerentscheidungen geben wird. Ähm und das Entscheidende ist, heute ist es ja nicht besser,
Ja, also wenn du du hättest ja immer noch den Vorteil, dass diese äh dass dass du eben nicht mehr
Willkür hass, weil das ist das, was ja
eigentlich das Problem ist. Wir haben ja mit dem Begriff der Diskriminierung in der letzten Sendung längere Zeit jongliert und es wurde dann auch in den Kommentaren mehrfach angemerkt, dass ich den,
halt in so einer rein wissenschaftlichen Dimension von, das ist Diskriminierung, ne? Also es wird unterschieden. Ähm, gesehen habe und das ist aber natürlich gesellschaftlich etwas andere noch gibt. Ähm.
Aber äh der äh der interessante ist eigentlich der Teil der Willkür, ja? Und die hast du halt dann nicht mehr,
Und heute hast du halt irgendwie, was weiß ich, heute wartest halt länger.
Auf deine Scheibe Wurst beim bei einer Wursttheke, weil die Wurstverkäuferin dich wirklich.
Oder so, ne? Also.
Ja, ich meine, das ist eh schon gesagt, wir wir bräuchten halt Transparenz darüber die Frage ist, ob wir eine Debatte haben können, gesellschaftlich über diese Entscheidungen, die da,
bei uns getroffen werden. And ich befürchte halt, dass das alles Geschäftsgeheimnisse sein werden, sowohl die Daten, wie natürlich die Algorithmen, die wenn sie im Maschine Learning sind, ja auch gar nicht nur begründbar sind. Da gibt's ja keine Kausalitäten.
Du erkennst den äh den Hack den ich mit dieser Anforderung.
Gestellt habe. Versucht habe zu stellen in der öffentlichen Debatte. Aber ähm unser Gespräch hatte ein hatte natürlich sofort äh politische Konsequenzen. Ähm Google hat äh Boston Daniels jetzt
abgestoßen wollen, äh wollen äh Boston Dynamics verkaufen. Äh das heißt die äh die die neu die neuen
Artificial Intelligence Overlords äh werden keinen Körper haben, sondern nur ubiquitär sein.
Ja ist halt die Frage angeblich, hat dieses Posten Dynamics Team nicht so gut im Team funktioniert.
Aber ähm ich meine im Kunde steht da natürlich auch die Frage, wie langfristig das alles ist, was Gool jetzt unter Alphabet macht
Also die ähm nur kurzfristig auf Profite schauen oder wenn's darum geht, dort Produkte an den Staat zu brennen. Ähm
welche Produkte sind das? Ja, ich glaube, da ähm ja, da gibt's auch einen längeren Blumenberg Artikel dazu, ähm der, der da scheinbar auch sehr viele interne Quellen aufarbeitet und den verlinken wir natürlich.
Mhm.
Ja und in Deutschland ist gewesen. Ist jetzt vorbei gerade. Ich war zum ersten Mal auf der C-Welt. Ich war äh noch nie auf der Zebel.
Ähm ja wie erwartet, also ich war ja nie auf der Cebet, weil mich ja alle gewarnt haben,
Also du kriegst ja dann immer so äh kriegst dann immer so Ehefreiticket äh zur Cave, die müssen das ja irgendwie äh dass die liegen ja inzwischen diese Tickets liegen ja offenbar äh wie ein Stein im Regal. Ähm.
Ja, es ist halt eine Verkaufsmesse, ne? Da wird halt äh oder eine,
Businessmesse, da wird halt Business gemacht und ähm wenn man schon mal eine besucht hat, dann äh weiß man halt auch, was einen da erwartet. Ähm insofern fand ich's noch nicht mal so tragisch. Ähm.
Du kommst halt irgendwie rein, ich bin ja durch den Haupteingang gegangen und dann das erste, was da steht, ist irgendwie so ein riesiger äh na ja, erstmal stand ich irgendwas von.
IBM äh irgend so ein Slogan, aber das erste, was ich gesehen habe, war ein großer Trecker von John Deere. Ähm.
Die die der Stand herum, weil ja ne, die Trecker kommen jetzt auch ins Netz, die werden ja klug. Und das ist ja tatsächlich schon so. Ich meine, das äh hier autonomes Fahren und so, ne, das hast du ja tatsächlich
schon heute, dass dir im Prinzip dein Mähdrescher da durchs Feld pflügt mit einer vorgefährlichen GPS-Route und da sitzt halt nur noch ein,
ein Mensch drauf, falsch ein Reh kommt, weil
teuer ist, wenn das Reh in den Mähdrescher rennt und deine komplette Ernte halt dann rot ist, das verkauft sich nicht so gut, weil ne,
und äh insofern war das auch natürlich klar, dass äh dass da halt äh Landwirtschaft äh,
ist. Aber die hatten halt ein ein Slogan und das war echt geil, da habe ich so eine kleine Fotoserie gemacht. Outfinkomplexity,
Wif Industrie vier null. Hier, ich zeige dir mal, guck dir das an.
Oh
Complexity ist eigentlich echt ein geiler Slogan so, ne? Also äh sei sei sei klüger als die Komplexität. Das ist schon, finde ich, finde ich einen geilen, also werbemäßig irgendwie eine eine gute Idee.
Offenbar haben die sich halt irgendwie so äh gedacht, ja okay, ähm die äh dieses Industrie vier null, das die.
Schien mir so, dass dir das absichtlich machen, um so dieses, diesen German Engineering äh Flow da reinzukriegen. Weißt du so? Also so quasi so eine Zeitlang weil alles was aus dem Valley äh ein lustiges Startup war, war halt,
fehlte halt das E-Format, flettere, äh, ne, Tindere oder wie der die ganze Scheiße heißt, so ist er jetzt auch wieder vorbei
und dass sie jetzt so sagen so okay krass wir schreiben halt bestimmte Wörter, die in Englisch und Deutsch sehr ähnlich sind einfach auf Deutsch rein. So fand ich noch nicht mal so
Aber okay, ist halt schief gegangen so, ne. Da habe ich mir natürlich das BSI besucht und habe mir eine Jutebeutel vom Bundesamt äh versichert in der Informationstechnik besorg.
Kotztüte.
Und dann die meine Lieblingstüte ist aber die von der Microsoft Cloud, das ist so eine schwarze Tüte mit einer dunkelgrauen, einer roten und einer gelben Wolke und da steht Microsoft Cloud drunter, weil die.
Das ist schon voll die Datenlokalisierung.
Genau, die, die haben das ja jetzt gemacht mit mit T-Systems zusammen irgendwie die Dinger, ja dann auch finden Complexity, dann natürlich irgendwie dann gab's ein krasses Diagramm.
The Future of Cloud. Also Cloud eins Punkt null war Virtualisierung, Cloud zwei Punkt null war Software, die Fine Computing, Storage in and Network.
Und das Cloud drei Punkt null wird Cloud Native and Platt Plattform Azer Service, also Cloud drei null wurde ausgerufen.
Äh Microsoft hatte dann glaube ich noch das digitale Wirtschaftswunder am Stand. Ähm IBM hat also IPM hatte relativ viel Platz und hatten dann einen Teil in ihrer Messeite, immer dann irgendwie so,
IBM und Lin und Lind und Sprungly, Chocolate Ghost Cloud. Also spätestens da weißt du halt wirklich weit, was.
Bist du da mit dem Bull mit der Bullshit-Bingo-Karte herumgelauf.
Ich hab das anfangs versucht, aber das irgendwie,
intelligenter Lebensmittelfluss gab's dann noch und super geil fand ich in der China-Ecke äh waren irgendwie so welche, die haben äh Postes verkauft, also Point of Sales Terminals, also es sind im Prinzip eher, sage ich mal, Kassensysteme, ne? Und die Firma hatte den schönen Namen,
Microposs und du siehst auch am Logo, dass sie, wo sie dir vorher sichere Inspiration hatten, ne. Ähm.
Ja ist halt äh ist halt eine Verkaufsmesse und entsprechend sieht's aus. Ähm Microsoft hat seine Schlangcloud da beworben, äh Industrie vier null war das große Ding Cloud, war das große Ding. Wir haben ja noch ein paar andere Buzzwords grade schon von von Günner gehört.
Und dann gab es da noch die Bekanntgabe oder den Launch der.
Plattform Trusted Cloud. Und das ist äh das will ich eigentlich auch nur nochmal kurz behandeln. Ich hatte das vor vielen Sendungen schon mal erwähnt, dass es das gibt.
Ähm also es ist ja schon irgendwie inzwischen offenbar, dass sage ich mal äh.
Die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, so mit diesem ganzen IT und so weiter, jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwie ein ein enormer Player ist, ne? Also du hast diese ganze.
Hardware und Softwaregeschichten im Valley, da wird ihm das große Geld gemacht so und so irgendwie German.
German Engineering und so, ja, das hat sich jetzt irgendwie, das versuchen, sie hat hier nochmal jetzt zu
zu pushen, ne? Aber so insgesamt ist es Deutschland jetzt nicht so die IT-Nation, ne? Woher auch mit unserem Pa Mbit, äh die wir da irgendwie haben, ne? Und.
Insbesondere haben sie natürlich dieses ganze Clouding verkackt, also die die deutschen Anbieter so, ne, haben es nicht geschafft
Und deswegen haben wir ja auch so Debatten, dass irgendwie äh wir uns irgendwie
Microsofts dann gesetzlich zwingen müssen, Datenzentren in Deutschland zu unterhalten oder so, ne? Um da irgendwie eine überrechtliche Hoheit. Aber so aus Wirtschaft, aus wirtschaftlichen Erwägungen.
Entstehen keine fetten Weltinfrastrukturen an Netz in Deutschland. Ja, also.
Es gibt einen Internetknoten und so, aber das Business ist hier halt einfach nicht so groß.
Also ich glaub.
Gemessen am Weltmarkt.
Was man hier auch äh als Wirtschaft versteht, ist ja jetzt nicht das ähm man versucht aus Deutschland heraus
aktiver Services anzubieten und hier mal wirklich gute Bedingungen für Startups zu schaffen, äh sondern dass man eher versucht so die klassische Industrie, wo Deutschland immer noch stark,
die jetzt so äh in ins ins Netz zu bringen und ähm sozusagen anstatt äh wirklich eine närrische, eine generische, neue Netzwerkschaft aufzubauen und sich zu fragen, woran das bis,
gescheitert ist, geht mal her und versucht so die klassischen Maschinenbauer mit diesem Thema zusammenzubringen.
Äh für mich steckt halt immer auch äh wieder diese,
Neoliberale Politik drin, ähm, Begriff, den wir noch nicht genannt haben, der für mich im Bullshit-Bingo in letzter Zeit aber ganz hoch im Kurs steht, ist Gigabit-Gesellschaft. Ähm,
ist auch was neues Lieblingswort von Oettinger und natürlich auch von der Telekom-Branche und keiner weiß noch genau, was Gigobit-Gesellschaft ist. Wir sollen die E-GoBit-Gesellschaft sein, also,
ist sowohl 'ne Aufforderung an die Gesellschaft digital zu werden wie auch eben wahrscheinlich 'ne Deckmantel für die Finanzierung von von veralteter Kupfertechnologie. Ähm,
wobei angeblich jetzt auch schon ähm über Glasfaser gesprochen wird ähm und äh
da werden halt die richtigen Fragen nicht behandelt, nämlich wie wie es dann wirk,
am freien Netzzug aussieht, äh, welche urheberrechtlichen Schranken wir haben äh Netzneutralität zuerst mal, wenn wir irgendwie versuchen, hier in Europa kompetitiv zu sein, vor allem mit den USA, müsste das die Vorbedingung überhaup,
Und das äh es ist es ist erstaunlich wie viel Politik hier gemacht wird ohne wirklich was zu sagen.
Ich will nochmal ganz kurz auf dieses Trasse Cloud-Ding zurück, ja? Also das ist eine diese Plattform ist jetzt gelauncht
Die haben dann auch mir wurde das mal zugespielt, irgendwie so ein äh Leitfaden irgendwie zur Auswahl deiner Cloud, aber du kannst ja schon, wenn
die wenn das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hingeht und sagt, wir machen irgendwie äh Trusted Cloud, dann heißt das natürlich, es gibt ein Kriterienkatalog für Cloud Services,
ja? Und in dem wird halt okay, der scheint jetzt inzwischen auch öffentlich zu sein. Ähm,
In dem geht es natürlich um Gütesiegel und Zertifikate.
Und dann kannst du dir natürlich vorstellen welche Gütesiegel und Zertifikate die da im im Kopf haben, ne? Also die wollen natürlich ähm.
Ne, es ist halt vom Wirtschaftsministerium.
Und das soll ist für die deutsche Wirtschaft so, das heißt die werden jetzt quasi ihren abgefahrenen Cloud Zug äh quasi über Zertifizierungen und so weiter.
Zurückkriegen wollen, ja? Das ist halt quasi die Leute sagen können, ja ich bin hier bei Trusted Cloud, Level fünf sind unsere Daten, ne? Und damit das halt irgendwie zum zum.
Zum Gütesiegel machen und zum Ansporn für für Unternehmen ebenso deutsche Cloud und sowas zu machen, ne.
Um damit halt quasi über solche Zertifikate und Siegel den den übermächtigen Leuten, die diesen Markt seit
Zehn, fünfzehn Jahren ganz einfach betreiben ähm äh irgendwie wieder äh was wegzuden Marktmarktanteile wegzunehmen. Finde ich auch ganz schön, aber jetzt kommt der Hammer. Also wir sehen hier dieses Dokument ist irgendwie,
vierundsechzig Seiten geschrieben von Cap Gemini.
Unternehmensberatung.
Das ist 'ne Unternehmensberatung. Ähm.
Und dann haben sie eine Webseite und so und ich meine, letztendlich ist es halt eine Werbekampagne für was weiß ich, deutsche Cloud, Mittelstandslösungen, ne?
So und weißt du was dieses diese Plattform bisher gekostet hat den deutschen Steuerzahler ausgeschüttet vom Bundeswirtschaftsministerium.
Trau mich nicht raten.
Was würdest du raten, wenn ich sage, es ist wirklich absurd hoch. Also du hast jetzt hier, wir haben das Dokument mal gesehen, du hast die Webseite gesehen.
Webseite siebzigseitiges PDF sagen wir fünfhunderttausend Euro.
Fünfzig Millionen.
Fünfzig Millionen Euro hat das gekostet.
Ort. Aber es sind da wenigstens diese ganzen Gütersiegel jetzt fertig entwickelt mit Programm und Abnahme und.
Ich habe da mal irgendwie gedacht, so okay, der interessante Teil ist natürlich Auswahl und Vertrag, klickst jetzt auf die Webseite, ne? Fragst du dich als erstes, welchen Bedarf haben sie.
Zweite Frage ist, welcher ist der richtige Cloud-Service für ihren Bedarf? Haben sie im ersten Schritt die groben Koordinaten für ihren Bedarf festgelegt? Folgt die Auswahl eines geeigneten Services. Finden sie heraus, wer hat, was sie wollen. Erstens.
So beginnt die Suche. Suchen sie nach Cloud-Services und Cloud-Anbietern, die alle ihre Mindestanforderungen erfüllen. Ja, natürlich.
Aber hier gibt's keine Lichte oder so, also mit suchen sie meinen Sigulensuche.
Ja, das wird natürlich, das soll natürlich irgendwann weitergehen, ne? Also die wollen äh dass dass Leute dann eben Trusted Cloud äh B, ja, äh haben, aber das ist äh ähm.
Also das ist halt, das ist halt so funktioniert halt Wirtschaftsförderung, ne? Und es gab ja schon vor ein paar Jahren, das habe ich auch im Logbuch behandelt, äh irgendwie dieses BSI äh Cloudding.
Und ähm da habe ich ja dann, das habe ich ja dann auch mal angeführt, als eben eine der dieser Wirtschaftsförderungs äh.
Sachen des des BSI und dieses Ding kommt halt jetzt einfach mal Hardcore direkt vom Wirtschaftsministerium. Aber ich meine, ey fünfzig Millionen an so eine so eine Idiotenberatung, ja,
also das ist wirklich äh.
Ich meine, es es gibt natürlich reale Probleme, die die man angehen sollte, also äh in Sachen äh IT-Sicherheit und,
hier vor allem durch die neue EU-Datenschutzgrundverordnung
Privacy bei Design und Budifuld, da ist schon enormer Entwicklungsaufwand zu leisten und äh das das ist nicht schlecht, wenn man da von von Wirtschaftsministerium offensiv auf diese Probleme zugeht und versucht, dass Firmen einfach zu machen, aber das sehe ich halt in diesem Projekt.
Und ähm dass das äh Ding mit den Güterseln werden wir in Zukunft noch mehr sehen, weil bei der Datenschutzkunstverordn,
Möglichkeit äh diese hohen Strafen, die in dem Gesetz nummeriert sind, äh auf ein Minium zu drücken, wenn man Gütesiegel abschließt.
Und die Gefahr steht halt im Raum, dass es da eher so ein,
verbessern und Rennen nach unten gibt und dann hat einfach dann Datenschutzablasshandel bei irgendeiner Beratungsagentur machst und dann ist halt was Gutes, Siege, im Zweifelsfall, im Verruf, aber das Unternehmen, das
den Detablige hatte ähm muss keine Strafe zahlen.
Mhm,
das Siegel platzen. Musst du nochmal in fünf Jahren neues machen. Bis dahin hat's aber genug, damit dem Siegel verdient. Ja, diese, also diese, diese Zertifizierungssache ist sowieso so ein Grundsatzproblem eigentlich. Du du.
In der IT-Sicherheit hast du das ja.
Auch die ganze Zeit. Aber du willst halt oder du brauchst für Unternehmensleiter, Entscheider, äh Verantwortliche, eben eine Möglichkeit.
Dass sie aus dem Schneider sind, dass die brauchen einen definierten Zustand von ich habe alles.
Menschen mögliche getan oder ich habe hm ich habe nicht fahrlässig gehandelt.
Ne, das ist eigentlich das, das ist eigentlich das das Entscheidende, da willst du halt hin. Und wenn du das hink,
dieser Zustand, wie auch immer der definiert ist. Ähm das wird einfach der, das wird der sein, den alle anstreben. Und da kannst du natürlich äh durchaus äh ähm,
auch Akzente setzen, ne. Äh ich bin da mal interessiert, was äh passiert, wenn Versicherungen sich der Sache annehmen.
Wenn die nämlich sagen, so, pass auf, du willst hier dich gegen IT-Risiken versichern, alles klar? Kein Problem, machen wir. So ist jetzt so, ist, so hat es auszusehen, damit wir dein Risiko für Versicherbar halten. Weil das ist, ich mein, das ist im Prinzip das, ne? Du bist Geschäftsführer und da gibt's ein Risiko, das könntest du versichern
aber die dein deine Risikoeinschätzung ist so hoch, dessen Versicherer dich nicht versichert, dann bist du halt ganz klar in dem in diesen äh nicht mehr.
Zurechtfertigbaren Bereich. Na ja, ähm aber die genau da wollen genau an dem Punkt wollen ja dann eben auch wieder große Konzerne ansetzen und Lösungen bieten. Und gerade in diesem mittler Mittelstand.
Sehe ich auch wirklich inzwischen kaum noch eine andere Option. Ja, ich meine der der Mittelstand äh.
Kann, die können sich gar nicht alle irgendwie einen klugen Atmen holen. Die müssen halt dann,
Services von irgendjemandem einkaufen, die kaufen ihre Infrastruktur, ihre ihre gesamte Business-Logik halt dann bei einem Dienstleister, ja,
groß sind, haben sie, haben sie ihre eigene Infrastruktur, aber die ganzen Kleinen, die werden vermutlich früher oder später halt in, was weiß ich, in,
sich in Sales Force oder irgendwelchen Scherzen halt vollständig abbilden, die lassen ihr Unternehmen.
Zentralisierung. Ja, aber es ist äh der Punkt mit den Versicherungen, das finde ich wirklich spannend, weil eigentlich sollte da so ähm nach Sony und Ashley Medison der Groschen gefallen sein bei der Versicherung.
Eher irgendwelchen Sinne, ich würde fast sagen, der Grosch schon bei den Versicherungen müsste gefallen sein, dass sie Senior Kick, das Unternehmen hat überlebt so, der Schaden war gar nicht so groß. Das ist eigentlich meine Sorge, ne? Ich meine, Sony hat überlebt, Airley Medison hat überlebt ähm.
Vielleicht ist der Schaden ja gar nicht so groß.
Aber es geht ja nicht nur um um Daten äh Verlust, es geht ja auch um äh Sabotage, Spionagetechniken, gerade bei produzierenden Betrieben und so, ne? Da geht's jetzt gar nicht um Kundendaten. Ähm das ist nur das, was wir öffentlich halt immer diskutieren, ne? Naja.
Also Zebit war äh ja also war, es ist halt eine Verkaufsmesse und du man hat halt Bullshit Pingo, aber das ist in in jedem Geschäftsbereich.
Auf jeder Messe so, dass er halt irgendwie äh gepusht wird, äh wie nichts Gutes, ne? So ist das eben.
Mit Öttinger.
Der darf nicht fehlen.
Ach so, ganz kurz wollte ich noch erwähnen, es gab ähm.
Ich war zusammen mit Thorsten Schröder vom äh Chaos-Computerclub äh im Fernsehen. Ähm bei bei Quarks und Caspers,
jetzt ist mir was runtergefallen. Ähm zu zu so Rancim Ware, das äh habe ich auch mal verlinkt, das war ganz lustig, weil wir da mal ähm.
Also es hatte war eine relativ schwere Geburt dieser Beitrag, wir haben da viel mit äh mit dieser Redaktion so gesprochen, aber ich finde, es ist uns da ganz gut gelungen, ähm.
Mal wirklich vielleicht ein bisschen tiefer reinzuschauen, wie so ein Ding funktioniert und sowas halt in der, in einer Wissenssendung ähm ordentlich,
zu präsentieren. Also wir haben halt irgendwie so uns komplett angeschaut wie dieses dieses Locki funktioniert, haben das ja demonstriert
Thorsten hat das Ding dann nachher noch irgendwie in Disseshämmler geworfen und die Run Time Dibaga und irgendwie so die quasi die Krypto da drin sich angeschaut und so und das haben die halt auch tatsächlich so gesendet und das ist natürlich immer so. Die beiden Hacker. So, aber ähm das war
fand ich schon eigentlich mal.
Jetzt so, man sieht, dass das halt irgendwie öffentlich-rechtliches ist und dass wir uns mit denen ein bisschen Mühe gegeben haben.
Fand ich ganz fand ich fand ich ganz in Ordnung den Beitrag so.
Dass ihr jemand sechs Minuten gibt, um irgendwie so ein Thema zu behandeln ähm.
Und nicht irgendwie so da so diese Cyberschocker-Nummer fährt ähm.
Ihr musstet auch keine Skimasken aufhaben während dem Demoheck.
Nein, also ich ähm selbstverständlich gab es äh unterschiedliche Phasen in der Absprache, äh wo man dann,
sage ich mal, dass die Redaktion nochmal auf den äh Boden der Tatsachen zurückziehen musste.
Aber das ist halt, ne? Ich meine, die haben halt, äh, die haben halt auch Vorurteile, aber sie haben eben dann auch im Laufe des,
das gezeigt, äh dass sie äh die nicht nur selber überwinden, sondern sogar dafür sorgen, dass sie in ihrer Sendung sich bemühen zum Abbau dieser Vorurteile beizutragen und äh das ist ja der Anspruch, den man eine Wissenschaftssendung hat.
Ja äh die Sendung hat aber halber im Titel und so ganz haben sie sich davon der Erwartung des.
Man muss die Leute ja abholen wo sie sind.
Ja, aber das war auch egal, kann man, kann man sich mal anschauen, war ganz, war ganz nett. Aber wir wollen ja eigentlich über wichtige Sachen reden. Jetzt haben wir über Business und Fernsehen und äh Roboterethik gesprochen.
In Österreich gibt's aber eine Verfassungsklage.
Das ist ja wohl immer viel wichtiger als die Industrie vier null.
Ja ähm
Wir haben ja dieses neue Staatsschutzgesetz in Österreich, das irgendwie nach den ähm ersten Anschlägen, hier in der zweitausendfünfzehn vorgestellt wurde und dann
hat's lange Zeit so ausgesehen, dass wenn äh diese massive Kritik, die es an dem Gesetz gab aus allen Ecken der Gesellschaft gehört wird. Äh dann ist
Paris zwei passiert und das ganze Gesetz wurde in Eilverfahren beschlossen und
ist auch inzwischen durchs Parlament und auch durch den Bundesrat und auch der Bundespräsidents hat's abgesegnet, also es wird ab ersten Juli einen neuen Inlandsgeheimdienst in Österreich geben.
Und ähm wie das sich so gehört inzwischen. Äh in Nachsehfarber wird's auch eine Verfassungsklage dagegen geben
und der der AK Vorrat, ähm, das Klima, mein Arbeitgeber
in Österreich, der hat da äh ja auch schon von Anfang an sehr viel mitgearbeitet, dass dieses,
äh Öffentlichkeit erfährt und dass die Kritik gehört wird und vor allem eben auch juristisch. Wir haben äh glaube ich jetzt schon vier Stellungen Namen veröffentlicht zu allen Phasen des Gesetzes und auch in der Gesetzwerdung
und ähm in Österreich gibt's grob drei Arten, wie man ein Gesetz zum Höchstgericht bringen kann. Ähm,
Der schwierigste Weg ist durch die Instanzen, dass man sagt ähm ich habe einen Fall, den da gerade mit irgendwann im Landgericht ähm
Der hat dort verurteilt, Berufe dagegen und kommen eine Ebene höher und das kann ich halt bis zur allerhöchsten Ebene machen und dann dort angeben. Ich werde in meinen Grundrechten durch dieses Gesetz eingeschränkt und dann,
kann ich nach vielen Jahren und vielen Anwaltskosten mit diesem, mit diesem langen Verfahren dort vielleicht dazu kommen, ähm, dass das Höchstgericht sich das Thema annimmt.
Der zweite Weg ist der, den wir damals bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Österreich gewählt haben, indem man direkt zum Verfassungsgerichtshof geht, aber da ist der,
Spalt, den die Tür offen ist, natürlich nur ganz schmal. Und da haben wir in Österreich eigentlich keine wirkliche Chance ähm nach nach nationaler Rechtssprechung direkt zum Verfassungsgerichtshof zu gehen.
Aber,
Wir haben da was vorbereitet in der Kochsendung. Äh wir haben äh aus zweitausendzehn noch eine Klage vor dem europäischen äh Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte ähm anhängig in Straß.
Die beschäftigt sich genau mit dieser Frage
Die Vorlagefrage ist nämlich, wenn ich ein äh Überwachungsgesetz habe, wo ich äh nicht konkret beweisen kann, dass ich betroffen bin, weil das so.
Breitem Wasserüberwachung beinhaltet und einer Kommission, die sich um den Rechtsschutz kümmert, sodass es auch keinen Richter gibt, der das Ganze absegnen muss
dann kann ich äh
haben wir damals in Österreich versucht zu klagen, sind damit abgewiesen worden und eben jetzt zum europäischen Menschenrechtsgerichtshof gegangen und wir haben äh die Zusage vom Gericht, dass dieses Verfahren im ersten Halbjahr zweitausendsechzehn noch entschieden wird,
Es könnte auch wieder für andere Länder spannend sein, also eben auch in Deutschland äh bei der G zehn Kommission müsste das eigentlich auch Anwendung finden,
wenn uns der EGMR recht gibt, dann werden wir auf jeden Fall,
den Weg zum Verfassungsgerichtshof mit so einer abstrakten Individualbeschwerde wählen. Äh schon allein um diese Rechtstradition zu versichern und diesen Fok einzuschlagen. Du kannst bei Überwachungsgesetzen auch wenn,
ganze Bevölkerungsschichten erfassen und du nicht konkret beweisen kannst, dass du jetzt schon überwacht wurdest und in deinem Rechten eingeschränkt wurdest, trotzdem damit zum Gerichtshof ge.
Dann gibt's aber noch den dritten Weg. Und den haben wir auch gewählt
ähm zwar ein Drittel der Abgeordneten in Österreich kann ähm ein Gesetz direkt zum Verfassungsgerichtshof brennen
und ähm das ist der sicherste Weg, weil da gibt's keine Frage der Zulässigkeit, wenn ein Drittel der Abgeordneten
National oder Bundesrat sagen je das Gesetz passt uns nicht, wir wollen das prüfen lassen, dann muss es auch geprüft werden. Und der Ackervorrat Österreich hat jetzt eine
Partnerschaft ähm mit zwei Oppositionsparteien, die so eine Klage einbringen und wir dürfen sie ausarbeiten.
Das ist ja interessant, also wie mit welcher.
Mit welcher Maßgabe wurde diese diese Möglichkeit begründet? Also wenn wenn du das Drittel zusammen hast, heißt das ähm.
Also ich meine, werden, werden Gesetze normal werden Gesetze üblicherweise mit einer Zweidrittelmehrheit entschieden. Wie sind denn so die Mehrheitsverhältnisse.
Also normalerweise äh reicht eine einfache Mehrheit in Österreich, um ein Gesetz zu beschließen, auch dass es eine Verfassungsbeschimmung, dann brauchst du ähm drei Viertel der Stimmen.
Ähm für für gewisse Materien ist das notwendig, auch in diesem Gesetz hättest du das gebraucht, zum Beispiel für den richtigen Richter vorbehalt, hättest du zwei Drittel der Abgeordneten gebraucht, weil du damit Jan, da brauchst du einen neuen Instanzenzug.
Und der, wer eine Verfassungsbestimmung und dafür hättest du die Stimmen der Opposition gebraucht und.
Du kannst aber jedes Gesetz unabhängig davon, ob es ein Verfass einer Verfassungsbestimmung ist oder ein normales Gesetz mit einem Drittel der Abgeordneten prüfen lassen.
Das heißt, das muss sich dann der Verfassungsgerichtshof
anschauen, aber die entscheidet dann natürlich, je nachdem, welche welche Fragen die Abgeordneten stellen, welche Miche Klage das sozusagen ist, äh auch nur noch sachlichen Kriterien und auf Basis der Grundrechte und Verfassung.
Okay, aber das ist, ist das dann quasi eine Klage, die die Abgeordneten machen oder rufen die einfach das Gericht an und wollen mal was hören.
Es ist äh hänge mich nicht an den an den äh Bestimmungen auf Juristen haben's immer ganz schlimm gefunden, dass wir damals die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsklage
verfassungsklage genannt haben, weil im Grunde ist es ein Individualantrag, das ist der
richtige juristische Terminus dafür, aber es ist wie eine normale Klagschrift, das heißt du argumentierst da drin, wieso du glaubst, dass dieses Gesetz aus diesen und jenen Gründen verfassungswidrig ist
Und du stellst Vorlage Fragen, die der Gerichtshof beantworten muss und je nachdem wie du diesen Antrag baust, da gibt's nämlich auch äh eine hohe Kunst mit sogenannten Eventalanträgen, also wenn du irgendwie so,
Ein Fuß in der Tür hast, kannst du gleich wie eine Streubombe in alle möglichen Richtungen Fragen stellen
und äh wenn auch nur eine davon durchkommt, kannst du halt eben die Bestimmung, die du da anzweifelst, äh aufheben lassen oder reparieren lassen,
da kann man dann auch sozusagen recht genau
Detextpassagen und die es einem geht, die man gestrichen haben will äh angeben und dadurch äh halt auch sozusagen das Endresultat, auf das man abzielt vorweg.
OK und also ihr sagt jetzt OK ihr geht mit den, ihr geht diesen Weg mit den Abgeordneten, habt dieses diese Drittel dieses Drittel zusammen und.
Da wird Ende Juni die Klage eingereicht, das ist schon fix. Ähm und die wird der Acker vor Ort ausarbeiten. Wie gesagt, wir wir haben eine große Stärke im Verein schon immer gehabt, das sind unsere Juristen, die sind echt gut
Die haben vor allem die die haben wirklich Erfahrung auch was höchstgerichtliche Klagen angeht. Unser Anwalt hat schon damals das Rundfunkmonopol in Österreich abgeschafft vom EGMR. Äh eben die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgeschichte
Wir haben auch im kurzen Dienstwechsel wollten in Österreich mal E-Zigaretten verbieten, da haben unsere Anwälte auch äh ausgeholfen bei dieser Klage,
also die sind schon sehr gut darin solche höchstgerichtlichen Anträge zu bauen.
Aber eben das mit den Abgeordneten machen wir fix, aber das schreiben wir sozusagen nur die Klage und wir werden aber natürlich, wenn der EGMR uns Recht gibt, das lassen wir uns nicht nehmen, dann.
Klagen wir auch nochmal selber.
Sowieso gerade in,
Also wird auch auf der edrigen Generalversammlung ganz viel besprochen, so jetzt nach Seefabe, ist allen klar, wir müssen irgendwie nicht nur immer etwas wie machen und mit unseren Grundrechtsargumenten werden wir halt leider im Gesetzgebungsprozess oft nicht gehört
aber vor den Höchstgerichten zählen diese Argumente noch, vor allem im Datenschutz, wo wir halt eine gute Ausgangsbasis in Europa haben.
Litigation heißt das, oder?
Ja, das ist so das Begriff für strategisches Klagen, dass ich mir halt wirklich äh mal hernehme, so ich,
dieses EU-Gesetz, das will ich wegklagen. Da habe ich achtundzwanzig nationale Höchstgerichte, mit welchem habe ich die beste Chance, ähm das Gesetz äh zum EuGH zu brennen und dann mit der richtigen Vorlagefrage aufheben zu lassen,
an mehr oder weniger das, was Max Schrems äh gemacht hat, aber das äh wird halt jetzt so als Strategikkonzept anerkannt und da, da passiert grad viel.
Da sitzen dann Leute, gucken sich ein Gesetz an und denken sich, das müsste man auch mal schremsen. Vielleicht kriegen wir.
Der Begriff ist schön.
Äh ja äh das war's auch schon zum Staatsschutzgesetz. Ähm da äh gibt's gibt's viel Spaß in Österreich, der Ackerforder in Österreich. Äh macht macht keinen Scheiß. Ähm.
Ich habe auch noch ein anderes Thema mitgebracht, nämlich äh.
Netzneutralität äh ist ja irgendwie auch so mit Steppenpferd und wir sind gerade in dem letzten Feinschliff für eine neue Version von Safety Internet Punkt EU.
Vielleicht kurz aufhören. Wir haben ja schon lange drüber gesprochen, was da schiefgelaufen ist und wieso wir es im Oktober nicht geschafft haben, mit unseren Änderungsanträgen im Europaparlament und
das Gesetz, was wir jetzt in Europa haben, dieser neue Telekom Market Verordnung, die
eine gesetzliche Grundlage zur Netzzentralität liefert, ist halt nicht perfekt. Es hat sehr viele,
mehr deutliche Passagen, die man so oder so lesen kann und die ich schon in der letzten Sendung gesagt habe, jetzt geht's halt darum, diese Mehrdeutigkeit.
Auf eine konkrete Lesart runterzubrechen und diese schöne Aufgabe liegt bei den Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden.
Die sich unter dem europäischen Mantelberg, Body Your European Regulators auf Electronic Communications.
Krass geil, jetzt habe ich jetzt verstehe ich das endlich mal. Body of European, Regulatis auf Electronic Communication. Geil kann man sich sogar merken. Ich wollte äh Bereke, ich habe immer so an Bereck gedacht. Sorry.
Es ist noch ein bisschen verwirrend, weil auf Deutsch nennen sie das dann Geräk, Gremium der europäischen Regulierungsbehörden für elektronische Kommunikation, aber ich finde Berek viel schöner und alle sagen Ber.
Bergber.
Die also das sind halt in in Deutschland die Bundesnetzagentur und äh äh in in ähm Rumänien ist es ankommen, in österreichisch ist es die RTR. Es gibt überall solche Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden
äh Rundfunk, Telekom-Regulierungsbehörde.
Und äh diese diese nationalen Behörden ähm das sind halt die, die den äh Telkos auf die Firma schauen und äh im Zweifelsfall auch auf die Finger hauen, wenn die sich unsauber verhalten.
Die sind halt dafür da, dass dieser Markt funktioniert, dass das da Wettbewerb gibt, dass die Kunden auch das bekommen, was sie gekauft haben und in Zukunft sind sie halt auch dafür zuständig, äh für die Einhaltung der Netzneutralität zu sorgen.
Nun haben wir.
Nochmal ganz kurz, ähm also um diesen um das nochmal äh zu erfassen. Also die gibt es ja schon, was machen die denn noch.
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich von Land zu Land, also.
Deutschland die Bundesnetzagentur, die ist ja geht ja auch über Kommunikationsnetze hinaus, oder?
Genau, oft sind diese Regulierungsbehörden auch mit der Regulierung von äh Schienen, Strom, Gas, Netzen, Wassernetzen, zum Teil ähm beauftragt in manchen Ländern regulieren sie auch Inhalte, Anbieter, aber das sind nicht viele
Und das sind sozusagen die klassischen Regulierungsbehörden, die überall dort zum Einsatz kommen, wo du eigentlich so eine monopolistische Infrastruktur hast.
Und ähm je nachdem, welchen Regulierungsansatz du wählst, dass du halt eben zum Beispiel,
Stromnetz hat es sich jetzt durchgesetzt, dass du strukturelle Trennung machst,
oder das heißt du hast jemanden, der sich um das Netz kümmert und dann hast du Anbieter, die verkaufen wir dir den Strom drüber. Im Internet sollten wir das eigentlich genauso machen,
irgendwie eine öffentliche Glasfaserinfrastruktur gibt und dann halt verschiedenste Internetprovider, die dir den Internetzugangsdienst darüber verkaufen.
Das wäre schön, wenn es Wehrlasses oft so, dass wir da halt eher so monopolistische Olympopole Marktstrukturen haben mit
großen, großen Internetanbietern, die die Netze kontrollieren und dir gegenüber der Politik immer das starke Argument haben, aber wir müssen Geld verdienen, weil wir müssen ja in die Netze investieren.
Und immer wenn Unternehmen zu Big to fail ist und äh gegenüber der Politik auf einmal sinnvoll den Case machen kann, wir müssen Geld verdienen.
Dann gibt's halt ein Interessenskonflikt.
Und ähm oft ist es leider so, dass diese Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden halt eine Revolving-Door haben, das ist sehr nahe zu den Unternehmen sind, die sie eigentlich kontrollieren sollten.
Da ist halt jemand irgendwie ähm.
Kommt eigentlich aus der Industrie und macht dann halt fünf Jahre Regulierungsbehörde und äh sollte eigentlich seine ehemaligen Arbeitskollegen kontrollieren,
hat er nicht unbedingt immer den den stärksten Anreiz, äh, deren Geschäftsmodelle kaputt zu machen.
Hab hier gerade mal auf den Tätigkeitsbericht Telekommunikation und Post zweitausendvierzehn zweitausendfünfzehn der Bundesnetzagentur ähm.
Angeschaut, einmal kurz drauf und das Saal, also wenn man da jetzt irgendwie reinschaust, sieht das eigentlich eher aus wie so ein äh ich will ja Bundesnetzagentur damit jetzt nicht zu nahe treten, aber es klingt so ein bisschen wie so ein ähm.
Ja so ein Erfolgsbericht eines äh Branchenverbandes, ja? Also irgendwie so.
Schnelleres Breitband wird weiterhin nachgefragt. Insint Messaging-Dienste verdrängen klassische Modelle. Onlinehandel sorgt für Wachstum. Ähm,
Ja, weißt du, dass irgendwie so äh keine Ahnung, die Leute telefonieren weniger, aber so und so viele Millionen SMS, ja, irgendwie guckst du irgendwie hier diese diese Bilder zur Pressekonferenz an, ja? Und das ist deren Tätigkeitsbericht, ja?
Tätigkeitsbericht, Telekommunikation und Post äh Post der Bundesnetzagentur.
Und dann hast du hier so ein komisches Balkendiagramm, das mit äh neunundfünfzig Milliarden SMS.
Zweitausendzwölf der Höhepunkt erreicht wurde und dass weniger SMS geschickt werden. Ich mein das ist ein Geschäft, das gehört in Geschäftsbericht von des Branchen.
Unternehmen, die sie da eigentlich regulieren sollten, ja? Aber es ist nicht das, was die die regulieren ja.
Also es ist auch ein Witz, dass sie da der Sitz ist doch nicht ihre Tätigkeit, die haben die SMS doch gar nicht geschickt. Also und auch nicht vermittelt. Also das ist irgendwie ja keine Ahnung.
Es es gibt ja seit einigen Jahren so diesen Push, äh der so ein bisschen neliberal beflügelt ist, dass man ähm sich ja eigentlich versucht zurückzunehmen und den Markt das Richten
lassen und wenn der Markt dann gute Zahlen produziert, äh kann man das aus eigenen Erfolg verkaufen, sowohl in der Politik wie in der Regulierung
es ist meiner Meinung nach der falsche Ansatz, weil ähm das Einzige, was was auch in allen historischen Vergleichen bis jetzt dazu geführt hat, dass vor allem Internet gut funktioniert ist, Wettbewerb,
Und äh wir sehen aber leider gerade, dass vor allem auch äh von von der Kommissionsseite DJ Connect das Kommissariat von Günter Ettinger. Ähm man halt
genau von diesem Ansatz weggeht. Und anstatt Wettbewerb in diesen Markt reinzudrücken.
Versucht sich zurückzunehmen und der Markt sich dadurch immer mehr konsolidiert, Internetunternehmen kaufen sich auf und es gibt eine enorme Zentralisierung ähm.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Agenda äh die Nelikus schon hatte und Regulierungsbehörden stehen dem manchmal viel zu offen gegenüber.
Ähm das ist nicht gut. Und ähm ja, also diese,
Achtundzwanzig Regulierungsbehörden, ähm die es in jedem Land gibt, sollen jetzt diese Mehrdeutigkeit im EU-Netzneutralitätsgesetz,
auslegen und zu Guidelines kommen.
Diese Guidelines, diese Leitlinien sollen halt dazu führen, dass dieses einheitliche EU-Gesetz dann auch in allen Ländern einheitlich exekutiert wird, ja?
Wollen ja einen Digital Single Marke, dann bin Markt, wo äh ich irgendwie meinen Dienst auch in Portugal anbieten kann und dort dieselben Bedingungen vorfinde.
Das heißt, diese diese schwache Ausforderung der Netzneutralität, die wir äh ja kritisiert haben, wird jetzt in diesen letztendlich in dem Gremium,
ausformuliert.
Das ist das, was da passiert ist. Also oder äh das ist das, was jetzt passieren wird. EU-Parlament, äh Kommission Pipapo sagen irgendwie so und so.
Das den Rest überlassen wir den Regulierern und da sitzen jetzt halt die Regulierer und machen das schön in transparent im im Hinterzimmer.
Ähm es gibt eine massive Geheimhaltung über diesen Prozess
äh nicht mal ich kenne die äh Entwürfe davon. Ähm ich kenne teils äh was da debattiert wird an thematischen.
Und äh ich war, ich war auch auf einem offiziellen Event schon am fünfzehnten Dezember zur sogenannten Berex Dekröder Dahlock, wo die sich halt offiziell mal die Meinungen von allen
angehört haben von Zivilgesellschaft und Konsumentenschützern, von Inhalte, Anbietern und von der Telekom-Branche selbst
Und wir haben Fragen bekommen für diesen Steakholder Dialog. So zur Vorbereitung. Darüber wollen wir mit euch reden
Und wenn man diese Fragen liest, denkt man sich wirklich so, wir stehen jetzt am Tag null der Netzneutralitätsdebatte. Ähm also,
kann jetzt ein Onlinedienst, ein Spezialdienst werden. Erlaubt, welche Formen von Netzwerkmanagement,
wollen wir erlauben und welche sind eher schlecht für die User,
Also Adam und E verfragen der Netzneutralitätsdebatte sind das, womit die diesen Prozess gestartet haben. Nach einem zweieinhalbjährigen Gesetzgebungsverfahren.
Also da merkt man, wie viel der Gesetzgeber offen gelassen hat und wie offen der Ausgang dieses Prozesses ist.
Okay, ja. Angst. Also du meinst also, dass sie sich überhaupt noch mit solchen Fragen befassen, heißt ein Zeichen davon, wie unzureichend der das Gesetz ist.
Also man kann das auch wirklich so oder so lesen ähm und das ist jetzt das Problem. Die Regulierungsbehörden haben ein äh enorm schwere Aufgabe, weil der Gesetzgeber ihnen auch eine fixe Deadline gesetzt hat.
Diese Guidelines müssen allerspätestens Ende August zweitausendsechzehn auf den Tisch legen.
Uns seit November wurde das Gesetz veröffentlicht, also das sind so knackige neun Monate, in denen die alle diese Fragen klären müssen,
und jetzt wird's spannend. Dazwischen gibt's auch eine Konsultation. Was heißt diese Regulierungsbehörden fragen die Öffentlichkeit.
Was hält ihr denn von diesen äh Entwurf dieser Guidelines, die wir uns hier überlegt haben? Und das ist genau der Punkt, wo in den USA.
Die gesamte Debatte sich um hundertachtzig Grad gedreht hat, drei Komma acht Millionen Kommentare an die FCC geschickt wurden und von dem Proposel, was Netzneutralität klar abschafft,
hin zu einer sehr guten Regelung. Die Sache gedreht wurde. In Indien genau dasselbe,
Also in Indien drei, die indische Regulierungsbehörde ihren ersten Vorschlag gemacht hat zur Regulierung von OTT, over the Topplayern, also WhatsApp und so, der hätte auch vorgesehen, dass die alle zur Kasse gebeten werden. Und dann über eine Million Kommentare,
Und das Ruder wurde hundertachtzig Grad oben gerissen. Äh jetzt ist halt die Frage, auch im historischen Vergleich, wie viel schaffen wir hier in Europa.
Das ist so mehr oder weniger gerade woran ich arbeite, deswegen wir haben als das Netzwerk von Safety Internet EU äh eine neue Kampagne am Start, die jetzt ähm.
Ende März online gehen wird, wo wir genau diese Konsoltation aufmachen, wo wir es Menschen einfach machen, ihre Meinung in diesen Prozess einzugeben, selber zu sagen, äh welche Netzneutralität sie in Zukunft haben wollen.
Und diesen Prozess halt so weit wie möglich zu öffnen.
Und dafür wird so ein Fragebogen geben, weil Berek hat da auch überhaupt keine Formatvorgaben, die haben einfach gesagt, ja wir veröffentlichen,
Wenn wir fertig sind, diese Guidelines und bevor wir sie dann endgültig absegnen, lassen wir die Öffentlichkeit nochmal kurz drüber reden und schickt doch eine E-Mail an diese Adresse.
Können wir machen.
Ja. Äh genau. Äh haben wir uns auch gedacht.
E-Mail können wir.
Safety Internet ist halt eben der Zusammenschluss von zwölf Organisationen. Wir schauen auch noch, dass wir noch
weiter wachsen und da der der harte Bangemarkt ist halt jetzt wieder in all diesen europäischen Ländern äh wirklich auch Druck aufzubauen
Und das Schöne bei der Kampagne ist, wir starten nicht erst irgendwann im Juni, wenn diese Guidelines offiziell in Konstruktation gehen, sondern wir starten jetzt.
Also diese Kampagne ermöglicht dir jetzt schon diesen Fragebogen auszufüllen. Ähm! Damit machst du zwei Dinge,
du schickst eine E-Mail an deine nationale Regulierungsbehörde.
Weil die ja diejenigen sind, die am Ende entscheiden werden, alle achtundzwanzig und du gibst uns diesen Kommentar und wir schicken den dann an Berek, wenn die offizielle Konsultation startet.
Damit schaffen wir es halt, äh, jetzt schon Druck aufzubauen, äh, schon mal zu sammeln für die Konsultation, da möglichst inhaltlich gutes,
starkes Feedback schon auf Halde zu haben, was wir dann dort einreichen können und wir machen's den Leuten einfacher, dass du nicht
deine eigene Stellungnahme schreiben musst, sondern indem du einfach die Fragen beantwortest, um die es dabei geht. Äh in eigenen Worten, mit eigenen Beispielen aus deinem
Leben aus deinem Unternehmen, aus deinem Bildungsweg klarmachst, wieso Netzneutralität wichtig ist.
Was ist aus diesen Startups äh diese Startups für Netzneutralität geworden? Gibt's das noch so? Kann man mit denen da.
Weil du gerade auch Unternehmen sagst, ne? Also wir haben ja also wir jetzt als irgendwie diese was sind wir, keine Ahnung, Zivilgesellschaft, Aktivisten, sonst was, Idealisten, Szene, ja? Ähm haben ja begrenzte,
Reichweite ähm in in bestimmte Bereiche so. Ähm.
Und gerade dieser wirtschaftliche Aspekt ist eigentlich, glaube ich, der der
Ja, wahrscheinlich der der Wen überhaupt, der es halt rauszieht, ne? Ähm, ich wollte an der Stelle nochmal wieder dieses Buch von äh Tim Ruh empfehlen, The Master Switch. Das ist sehr ärgerlich, dass ich das jetzt andauernd empfehle, weil da habe ich tatsächlich äh
überdiel LNP-Adresse, weil er ein Rezensionsexemplar bekommt und also dieses Bucher jetzt schon dreimal empfohlen. Ähm.
Ich ich hab's mir selbst gekauft und ich empfehle es auch.
Äh du hast, du stellst exakt die richtige Frage. Ähm ähm ohne ohne koordinierter wirtschaftlichen Anstrengungen wird's nicht gehen, weil es gibt ja auch der Großteil äh der Wirtschaftssteakholder,
hat ja ein Interesse an Netzneutralität. Da geht's darum äh äh nicht nicht ein Wegegeld zahlen zu müssen, sondern einfach ein ein Wettbewerb
äh sicherzustellen auf Onlinewirtschaften. Das betrifft,
klassische Startups, die ähm nur Internetdienste anbieten, sondern auch äh deinen lokalen Nahversorger. Jeder, der irgendwie eine Website hat, über die er mit seinen Kunden spricht
Ähm, wir haben, wir haben inzwischen die Studien schon paar hundert Millisekunden mehr Laderzeit, haben einen enormen Auswirkung darauf, wie lange du verweilst auf einer Webseite und wie viel Geld du dort ausge,
Also dadurch, dass wir diesen Unterschied machen und andere erreichbar sind, äh manche erreichbarer sind das andere.
Hast du halt einfacher auch äh in klassischen analogen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen auf einmal einen Qualitätsunterschied.
Ich frage mich da gerade ähm also es gibt ja wo.
Es gibt ja relativ viele wirtschaftliche Bereiche, wo sage ich jetzt mal Staaten, gewisse Rollen spielen. Also ähm.
Ich versuche da jetzt also der Vergleich äh hinkt wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen, aber ähm kennst du den, der Sueskanal.
Ja, das ist doch irgendwie äh net, der Schaf, der man fährt zwischen Ägypten und ich war leider noch nie genau.
Ist da zumindest dran, aber ich glaube, er gehört nur Ägypten, weil er wurde ja letztens auch ausgebaut und da war großes Dontamen.
Genau, also du hast auf jeden Fall eine, du hast eine riesige ähm du hast eine riesige Abkürzung.
Für den Güterverkehr mit Schiffen. Und das heißt der partizipiert ein Land, das im Prinzip nur diese Abkürzung hat,
melkt dann ja quasi den den Schiffsverkehr, ne? Die haben diese Infrastrukturskanal geschaffen, ähm womit du irgendwie weißt nicht wie viel Tage oder sonst was irgendwie Umweg sparst oder Wochen, ich weiß es nicht, ich bin
Geographie war, weil ich nie so der hält. Ähm.
Die ermöglichen dir da eine Infrastruktur und der durchzufahren kostet halt irgendwie, weil sie ist auch irgendwie schweineteuer, da sind halt immer direkt immer so sechsstellige Beträge oder so. Aber die Zeit, das sparst du halt an Sprit und Zeit äh und deswegen heizen die ganzen Schiffe dadurch. Und ähm.
Das hält eigentlich dieses Land. Äh da ist ein signifikanter Finanzierungsfaktor für die, für die Betreiber, die.
Weder die Güter produzieren, noch die Schiffe noch sonstwas, aber halt eine Möglichkeit haben gefunden haben, quasi da an einem Markt äh zu partizipieren
ja? Und äh ich frage mich, ob das so, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die Idee ist, die halt die Infrastruktur äh betreiber äh so so jetzt für sich sehen, ne? Dass man sagt, okay, äh oder ähm.
Debatte, die du ja auch in Deutschland hattest, hauptsächlich glaube ich von dem, äh, ich weiß nicht, ob das der Seehofer war, der die äh angeleiert hat, äh nee, Quatsch, SEO. Also, die, diese Idee des,
Güterverkehrs durch Deutschland. Also du fährst Waren durch Europa, so fährt jemand, liefert jemand was von äh von Polen in die Niederlande so
der fährt über deutsche Autobahnen, der nutzt unsere Infrastruktur,
Nehmen uns die Parkplätze weg, ne? Und äh ne dann besteuerst du die halt, ne? Also Ausländermaut und solche Geschichten, die da alle immer debattiert werden, dass man sich im Prinzip denkt, so okay, das, was wir hier haben, ähm das wird jetzt nicht.
Wird halt wenn da jemand Geld darin verdient, dann wollen wir davon was abhaben, ne? Hättest ja den Sojaskanal auch einfach. Gut, der war relativ teuer, aber den haben die ja, der ist ja künstlich angelegt,
Ähm der den muss man dann auch irgendwie wieder monetarisieren oder so, klar. Aber äh ich glaube, dass die Chipsbetreiber sich wahrscheinlich gedacht hätten, weißt du auf Dauer wäre günstiger gewesen, den Landstrich zu kaufen. Wir hätten alle zusammengeworfen, da der durchgebaggert und äh gut wär's, ne?
So diese also Staaten agieren halt in anderen Bereichen auch so, dass sie quasi versuchen.
An funktionierenden,
an funktionierenden Märkten in irgendeiner Form zu partizipieren. Und dass sie zum Beispiel, was die wahren Einfuhr und Ausfuhr von äh Staaten angeht, äh hast du ja auch alles Mögliche über das machst du ja mit Zöllen
ja? Dass du irgendwann sagst, keine Ahnung. Äh die Chinesen äh liefern uns irgendwie zu billiges äh zu billiger Batterien
jetzt gibt's irgendwie Einfuhrzölle auf Batterien, damit die deutsche Batterie
Produktionselite nicht gefährdet wird oder so, ne? Und das das daran erinnern mich eigentlich so diese diese Themen über die wir jetzt gerade reden, Netzneutralität äh,
Cloud Siegel, ne? Also, dass du quasi im Prinzip Wirtschaftskriege äh führst äh über Einfuhrzölle und ähm.
Macht das Sinn oder was habe ich da.
Ja, ja, na, also es ist äh ich meine die Leute, die hier ähm hier die politischen.
Ähm Agendas schreiben, die die Punktation vorlegen,
die die waren ja auch in all diesen analogen Bereichen schon unterwegs und das ist einfach die klassische Denke, die jetzt hier umgelegt wird auf auf neue Technik
ähm und du hast halt vor allem für für die Frage der Netzzentralität ist das etwas, dass wir aus
den Telefonmarkt schon kennen. Das sind die Terminierungsmonopole, dass ich als ähm als als ähm Mobilfunkoperator äh sozusagen für das ähm,
Abnehme des Calls, der mit meinem Netz endet, bekomme ich Geld,
und ähm das äh dieses dieses Zugangsmonopol, was ich für meine Kunden habe, das siehst du halt auch im Internet, da geht's ja darum, andere Firmen verdienen mit meinen Kunden, in meinem Netzwerk Geld. Und davon will ich ein Stück haben,
Ähm nur ist es aber so, dass wir äh über Jahrzehnte gesehen haben, dass diese Terminierungsmonopole mit ein Grund sind, wieso dieser Telekommarkt so,
ungesund und und Oligopol ist, weil du halt einfach immer als großer enormen Vorteil gegenüber allen Kleinen hast.
Genau, weil der Kleine es sich nicht leisten kann, die ganzen,
Terminierungsgebühren zu zahlen, wenn ich jetzt einen kleinen, billigen Telko mache, äh dann und die und die Leute rufen damit die ganze Zeit bei der Telekom an, dann sagt die Telekom, ah Neumann hier, schöner Telko hast du da. Ähm mit uns hast du übrigens neunzig Prozent deiner Telefonate und das kostet.
Das heißt du ja hast.
Schönen Mechanismus, der jeden neuen Player da irgendwie sofort rausekelt eigentlich, weil er sich nicht leisten kann, mit dir zu konkurrieren.
Genau und da haben wir das das reine Wettbewerbsargument, aber natürlich geht's beim Internet auch um die andere Schiene, dass wir hier äh ähm einen enormen Innovationsraum verlieren,
Rent Provider jetzt anfangen. Äh äh weniger Prozent Umsatzbeteiligung
um die deutsche Telekom zu zitieren von allen Startups zu verlangen, äh dann ist es nicht mehr zu leisten. Start-ups nicht die Kohle, für jeden Provino, dessen Kunden sie potentiell erreichen wollen, Geld zu zahlen,
nun dort irgendwie in wettbewerbsfähigen Dienst anzubieten.
Ja äh da da aber das ist also das Herr also bei der stimmt. Ähm.
Strategie der deutschen Telekom scheint eher zu sein, äh dass sie dass dass sie die Startups zu sich ziehen wollen,
Also du hast eine innovative Idee, ne? Und sagst okay, das Ding könnte groß werden und dann sagt die Deutsche Telekom, ah schöne Idee hast du da, ist doch super. Die Idee fördern wir.
Mit, indem wir Anteile an deinem Unternehmen, wir investieren in dein Start-up und wenn du mit uns,
Sollte es ja auch bedenken ähm dass du uns einen guten Preis machst, weil wir machen deinem Startup ja nachher auch einen guten Preis, wenn's ans Internet will. Und ähm.
Wenn du das nicht machst,
Hast du natürlich ein Risiko für dein Startup unter Umständen halt äh hohe Wegzölle an die Telekom abtreten zu müssen. Das heißt, das Angebot, mit dem die Telekom an dich in der frühen Gründungsphase deines Unternehmens herantritt, ist, hm.
Wir könnten einfach einen Teil deines Businesses bekommen, da geben wir dir sogar Geld für.
Oder aber du gibst uns keinen Teil deines Businesses.
Dann geben wir dir kein Geld, sondern nur du uns Geld, wenn dein Business groß ist. Weißt du? Das heißt und dadurch würden die sich quasi dann diversifizieren
und für sich als träges Unternehmen es schaffen ähm Innovationsprozesse quasi äh abzugreifen und zu begleiten und diese Unternehmen halt dann mit hochzuziehen.
Und quasi die Innovation in ihr Monopol äh oder in ihre marktbeherrschende Stellung mit reinzuziehen.
Ist das, was sie wahrscheinlich machen werden. Oder danach sieht's aus.
Ist eine Tukes Strategie, weil daran haben sie, daran sind sie immer gescheitert. Diese äh die Innovationskraft hast du in großen Konzernen einfach nicht. Aber die kann man sich ja dazu holen, die kann man sich kaufen,
Und ähm dadurch äh kannst du halt beides haben. Du hast einerseits ähm die marktbeherrschende Stellung, du hast viele Kunden, du kannst entscheiden, wie gut welcher Dienst dort angeboten werden kann
und gleichzeitig hast du innovative Dienste, die du als Argumente verwenden kannst, wieso das, was du hier tust in Wirklichkeit ja, die Innovation ist, die kommt jetzt halt als Spezialdienst vermarktet,
Ähm.
Aus aus deren Sicht macht das alles Sinn. Es ist aber, wenn man sich dann anschaut, äh dass das heißt aber auch, im Grunde wird dann jede neue Innovation, die wir in Europa produzieren, nur in,
Kooperation mit irgendwelchen großen äh Telekom-Unternehmen passieren können. Ähm,
gleichzeitig aber dort wo es wirklich um Geld geht dort wo dann amerikanische Unternehmen derzeit die großen großen Blatthirschen sind mit Abstand äh werden wir auch keine Konkurrenz mehr zulassen, weil natürlich wird Google zahl,
Es ist natürlich für die Absicherung so einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung.
Genuss. Ja. Gerne. Wie viel Volta? Kommen wir Runden auf. So, hier gehen wir, holt euch noch ein Eis. Ja klar.
Also darum.
Und das ist aber, aber was sie, also was die Telkos ja auch immer haben wollten,
oder was sie immer wieder bemüht haben, so als Zug fährt zu haben, sind Features, die es nur bei ihnen gibt.
Weil irgendwie telefonieren kann jeder inzwischen mit seinem Handy und du kriegst bei den meisten Netzen jetzt auch so irgendwie häufigst deine Blitz dadurch, ne? Ähm.
Aber was du ja eigentlich haben möchtest, ist irgendwie diesen schönen Login
du irgendwie über die Telefonnummer hattest und dann haben sie dir das irgendwann weg
genommen, dann konntest du mit den Telefonnummern umziehen. Dann klammerst du dich irgendwie wie so ein Iran an deine vierundzwanzig Monatsverträge und das funktioniert auch irgendwie ganz gut, aber wenn du Pech hast, regulieren sie dir das auch irgendwann mal weg
Dann wird's halt irgendwie, denkst du jetzt so, ja, Facebook müsste man sein, ne? Man müsste irgendwas haben, was alle anderen nicht haben und auch nicht haben können, ne.
Musikstreaming. Genau, so, dann machen das die anderen auch. Aber wir haben bei denen die die beschisseneren Anbieter, ne? Also irgendwie bei ich bin ja hier bei äh.
Ich bin ja Unterschicht, also habe ich ja auch in Unterschichten Provider. Äh hier der der BLZDWM TV, sonst was Flat, ne? Also irgendwie ordentliches Spotify äh kann man sich da leider nehmen. Kinder gibt's dann halt nicht.
Das sehen wir grade in diesem Musikstreaming-Markt in Europa sehr schön, weil da gibt's eigentlich in fast jedem Land diese Double Exclusive Partnerships, also du hast den einen Provider, der hat,
Spotify, als Partner, kriegst du irgendwie um zehner dazu, ist gleich Cirated, musst dir um das Datenvolumen keine Sorgen machen, der andere Provider hat dann dieser
Du hast in beide Richtungen exklusiv Verbindungen. Spotify wird in diesem Land mit keinem anderen Mobilfunkprovider was machen. An der wird natürlich nicht mehr als einen Musikstreamer anbieten,
Dadurch hast du grade wieder diesen Logineffekt, weil Leute haben ihre Playlists auf diesem Ding, haben da vielleicht sogar ja soziales Netzwerk irgendwie integriert und du wirst nicht deinen Musikstreaming, wo du ja nur noch Nutzungs, aber keine Besitzrechte an deiner Musik,
den wirst du nicht so schnell wechseln.
Und das Spannende ist, dass äh also das ist das eine Argument, diese eine Verhinderung von Monopolen ist das eine, was immer noch tragfähig ist in unserer Gesellschaft. So, alles also.
Ich hoffe, im Internet äh ist äh leider keine äh realitätsnahe Idee mehr und,
das das Problem ist ja gerade eben auch im Mobilfunk, da haben wir's abzuschließen, das sehen wir halt auch, wie der Markt in den letzten Jahren äh äh sich ganz stark konsolitiert hat. Also es gibt jetzt nur noch ein paar kleine äh ein paar große Player.
Deutschland gerade geschehen wieder, ne? Einer weniger jetzt? Telefonika hat E Plus.
Also das das ist eine extrem äh besorgniserregende Tendenz, wenn wir auch äh anerkennen, was Internet eigentlich für eine Funktion in unserer Gesellschaft hat,
Als Infrastruktur der Daseinsvorsorge und dieser dieser Gesichtspunkt der kommerziellen äh der der kompletten Kommerzialisierung ähm.
Der, der es heute nicht im politischen Interesse sei. Und ähm da ist jetzt halt, das sind jetzt halt eben nicht mehr die Politiker, sondern die Regulierungsbehörden gefragt. Und sicherlich, das ist jetzt ein extrem harter Kampf an ein Apil Battle, aber.
Nicht versagen, sondern schau in die USA, schau nach Indien, das ist genau der Moment, wo wir's rumgerissen haben.
Und ähm unsere Aufgabe ist es jetzt, die Bedingungen zu schaffen, dass April, Mai, Juni, die heiße Phase der Netzzentralität in Europa wird.
Und die Kampagne sozusagen die Basis dafür, dann,
da hoffentlich noch viel mehr passieren, wo ähm wir eben auch mit Edri die Koordinationsrolle haben und diese ganze Kollektion äh sich auch immer freut, wenn sie wächst, da sind wir jetzt gerade dabei und ähm,
Nebenher, ich äh bin die letzten äh Wochen schon sehr viel durch Europa getourt, weil meine Rolle ist es auch mit den Regulierungsbehörden zu reden, da wo wir als Idri-Netzwerk keine starken Mitglieder haben,
mit den Behörden zu sprechen, weil oft haben die halt nur die Telekomsicht bis jetzt gehört und das.
Sind dann ähm teils wirklich tolle Debatten, weil die Leute das wirklich aufsaugen wie ein Schwamm.
Aber da müssen wir halt auch Panoropäisch besser werden, weil jedes Land hat gleiche Stimmrechte im Bereich. Das heißt auch in Litauen, äh, wo ich jetzt schon war, äh, die Leute haben ähm.
Weitaus weniger Ressourcen als andere Regulierungsbehörden, sehen die Frage, Herr Börs enorm wichtig an und je nachdem was für Erfahrungen die auch in ihrem Markt gemacht haben und welchen Druck die ausgesetzt sind, äh müssen sie halt auch ihre Entscheidung finden.
Was für eine Netzneutralität wollen wir in Europa haben? Und ähm die die Situation ist enorm unterschiedlich von Land zu Land.
Aber äh hat diese Analyse schon veröffentlicht im Dezember werden wir auch verlinken. Da kann man nachlesen, wie wir dieses Gesetz lesen und es fähre eben äh durchaus wirklich noch zu machen, damit genau die Netzneutralität zu bekommen, die wir wollen,
also auch klar verboten, Spezialdienste, nur dort, wo es äh einen technischen Grund gibt im Sinne von der Dienstwer übers Internet eh nicht machbar.
Bei Verkehrsmanagement darf's halt nicht dazu kommen, dass Provider ein Paket nach Mascher geben, wie wichtig sie sind, sondern das soll Applikation sagnostisch und nach Best Effekt passieren.
Und sag mal, die ähm diese Bäreksache wäre wirklich ähm also inwiefern ist da juristisch die Verbindlichkeit äh gesichert? Auf für das, was worauf worüber die sich jetzt einigen.
Oder ist das einfach nur der der äh das Kartell der der Regulierer.
Äh na ja, es hat äh rechtlich äh,
Muss man unterscheiden. Ähm wenn diese Guidelines eine klare Linie vorgeben, dann ist das mal der Standard, der gesetzt ist und ähm der wird.
Chance haben dann sicher auch zu beweisen. Rechtlich ist es natürlich so, dass äh nur das Gesetz wirklich die das Gewicht hat.
Für die Regulierer sind diese äh Guidelines bindend, also ich kann jetzt danach nicht hergehen und eben eine Regulierung machen, die äh außerhalb dieser Guideline steht.
Also die die Regulierungsbehörden müssen sich daran halten.
Aber natürlich kann ich vor Gericht ziehen und das Ganze bis zum EuGH treiben und dann das Gesetz neu auslegen lassen.
Mhm.
Okay, also safe the Internet, dot you im Auge behalten und aufpassen, dass wir uns alle schön an dieser Konsultation beteiligen, also irgendwie so eine Million
das kriegen wir doch auch hin, oder? Also das dürfte jetzt nicht so schwierig sein.
Ja, Millionen fände ich schön.
Ja? Also das ja wenn jeder Dritte Hörer.
Das wäre schön, ja.
Ja, also die die Website äh ist jetzt noch nicht, wir sind noch in der Beta, aber äh wenn das kommt und der Release passiert, dann wird's auch in diesem Programm hier zu hören sein.
Das sagst du so, da wollen wir mal sehen, mal gucken. Ja doch.
Ich schalte Werbung. Gut, genug Netzentralitä.
Du hast noch deinen zweiunddreißig C drei Vortrag hier verlinkt.
Ja, ich ich habe hier Linklist gemacht, ihr findet da. Ja, ja.
YouTube, wir linken auf Media CCD. Solange war das mit der Netzneutralität noch haben, äh nutzen wir das auch.
Ja, da habe ich keinen Launchbassarch-Templi dafür, sorry.
Ihr, wir, ihr findet den Link dann auf Media CCC DE und sonst sind eben noch ein paar ähm die die Berak, was sie selber sagt dazu zu diesem Prozess habe ich verlinkt und Edris Analysen zu dem Thema
da könnt ihr nachlesen, wenn ihr wirklich tief ins Thema einsteigen wollt. Kann ich euch empfehlen.
Jut, dann haben wir noch äh kurz zu erwähnen, ein Urteil des Landgerät nee, ein eine ähm.
Eine Meinungsäußerung des Generalanwalts äh äh des EuGH ähm der die Störerhaftung in Frage stellt. Und zwar war das so, dass da gab's irgendwie ein Verfahren vom Landgericht München.
Und da ging es um den Betreiber eines Geschäftes, also die eines Cafés oder so, äh in dem äh ein
illegaler Download äh stattgefunden hat, beziehungsweise wie wir ja wissen, die reduzierst nicht fürs Downloaden, abgemahnt, sondern fürs Uploaden, weil dein Torent Client eben
Die die Teile, die er hat ähm mit den Menschen,
teilt äh mit den anderen. Du bist quasi für das äh massenhafte zugänglich machen, wirst du abgemahnt, nicht für das herunterladen. Ähm und da war offenbar jemand in einem Café und hatte da einen Torwart laufen und dann hat der kam die Abmahnung an den Kaffeebetreiber.
Und der hat gesagt, ey nee, die Arschlecken, ich sitze hier mein Kaffee, äh ich war das nicht und ich kann relativ klar nachweisen, dass oder ich,
kann, ich habe Grund zu der Annahme, dass ich das nicht wahr, weil ich habe nämlich einen Kaffee mit dem WLAN, ja? Und da sind Kunden und die von denen habe ich, von denen habe ich nicht die Ausweise kontrolliert, so ne,
und.
Ja, dann kurzer äh Rand äh Notiz, das handelte sich um ein Album der Gruppe, wir sind Helden, die das,
an dem der Musikkonzern Sony,
die Rechte vertritt, äh, ne? Ehre, wem, ehre Gebühr an dieser Stelle und der Abgemahnte war ein Mitglied der Piratenpartei und der hat dann halt eine
negative Feststellungsklage gegen Sony Aromen. Das heißt, da irgendwie so, also die negative Feststellungslage ist ja quasi so dieses ne
du nimmst deine Abmahnung auch nicht zurück, sondern wir ziehen den Tier jetzt mal durch. Wir gucken jetzt mal. Ähm.
Und dann hat das Landgericht München eben gesagt, na gut, dann fragen wir doch mal äh in Luxemburg, äh wie wie das so einschätzen, ob wie das mit der Störerhaftung ist. Und der,
Generalanwalt Sponar, ja, heißt der wohl. Ähm hat die ähm die.
Richtlinie so verstanden, dass das die Störerhaftung an dieser Stelle eben nicht äh für den Betreiber gelten,
solle. Ähm hat aber gesagt äh dass das Gericht Geldbußen verhängen könne.
Wenn der ähm Kaffeebetreiber, Hotel oder Barbesitzer nichts gegen,
nachgewiesene illegale Downloads über sein Netzwerk unternimmt,
Das heißt, das wäre äh der, das wäre genau diese äh diese Sache, die man in der deutschen Regulierung ja jetzt auch gerade hat, dass man sagt, du musst etwas unternehmen,
das was du unternehmen musst, ist irgendwie den, denn
Kennwort Netzwerk muss verschlüsselt sein und du musst irgendwie die Leute äh die Leute müssen. Also es war ja dieser etwas äh skurrilere Katalog, der da äh in dem Gesetz steht. Aber was er sagt, ähm der Generalanwalt,
Insgesamt können die Nachteile eines umfassenden Schutzes von offenen Netzwerken für die Gesellschaft schwerer wiegen,
als die Vorteile für den Rechtinhaber, wenn er da jeden scheiß Download irgendwie mit äh über tausend Euro abmahnen kann, ne? Also dieses diese Abmahnindustrie ist ja nun wirklich ein ein.
Ein Schmerz im Arsch. So, das ist ja wirklich absolut äh nervig, ekelhaftes,
Geschäftsgebaren, was was sie da äh äh an den Tag legen. Ich habe auch immer wieder dann mal im Bekanntenkreis hört man so von Fällen, wo Leute irgendwie mal wieder erwischt wurden oder vor Jahren irgendwie, weißte.
Und erstaunst du wirklich, was die für Geld verlangen und wie die Gerichte unsere schönen Gerichte, die wir uns da hinstellen irgendwie mit tagtäglich mit so einer Scheiße äh befassen und irgendwie die Leute ähm,
Ja, da einen nach dem anderen abmahnen und die nehmet ihr halt wirklich von den Lebenden, ne? Also die, das sind die sind dann, dass die die Strafen, äh die da heute äh,
in den an den Gerichten entstehen und die die Abmahngebühren, die da heute verlangt werden, die sind also wirklich jeseits von jeder sinnvollen Rechtfertigung, ne? Also das ist wirklich
übel.
Das Ganze halt noch so dieses Geschäftsmodell und der Abmahn ist ein Geschäftsmodell, das ist nichts anderes, das ist ein Geschäftsmodell, was äh diese was diese Unternehmen,
trägt oder mit dazu beiträgt äh zu den Einkünften dieser Unternehmen.
Und insofern könnte man eigentlich echt sagen, so dieses ganze Störerhaftungsding, das ist irgendwie, du musst dein WLAN zumachen, Ding ist ein enormer gesellschaftlicher.
Also das wird dann noch teurer, ja? Die Menschen, die Menschen müssen nicht nur ihre tausend Euro bezahlen, äh weil sie abgemahnt wurden, sondern sie müssen auch noch wir müssen als Gesellschaft noch den Produktivitätsverlust in Kauf nehmen, dadurch, dass wir keine offenen WLANs haben
wie in jedem anderen Land, weißt du? Fliegst irgendwo hin, das erste, was dir hallo sagt, ist ein freundliches, offenes WLAN. Ja, ist doch geil.
Da freut man sich wirklich, am Flughafen zu landen, ja? Ja. Also ich ich seh's, ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt weitergehen, das ist ein gesellschaftlicher Schaden, der hier pa.
Irgend also meine ich.
Unter Risiko gestellt und äh es ist äh das ist jetzt ja die die ähm
Meinung des Generalanwaltes sozusagen die Vorlage fürs Urteil, was dann noch vom Richtersenat des EuGHs abgesegnet werden muss, aber in den meisten Fällen geht
Der Richtersenat in dieselbe Richtung und in dem Fall ist es wirklich zu hoffen, weil es ist längst überfällig, dass dieses ganze Thema.
Abmahnindustrie in Deutschland endlich äh in die Akten gelegt wird und das wäre auch genau die Aufgabe eben diese
Güterabwägung zu machen und zu sagen, nein, also hier ist das Partikularinteresse äh jemanden für zivilrechtliches Delikt zu strafen, einfach nicht verhältnismäßig gegenüber dem gesamtgesellschaftlichen Schaden und ich ich hof.
Gesamtgesellschaftliche Schaden und auch irgendwie ich mein auch das Ding für diesen Kaffeebetreiber. Ähm, also da muss ja auch mal überlegen ich geh doch nicht also ich will einfach vernünftiges Internet haben, wenn ich in Kaffee gehe,
Ja, also das ist irgendwie, das tut mir dann auch leid für die Kaffeebetreiber, ja, dass ich da nur reinkomme, äh aber weil's irgendwie letztens wieder ein bisschen, wie gesagt, unterwegs ist, dann brauchst du halt ein Netz und dann gehst du halt
in ein Café und kaufst dann da halt irgendwie so einen dämlichen Latte für vier fünfzig und bleibst nippst da eine Stunde dran rum und das Internet so, ne? Und das ist da äh so das machst du halt, weil da dran steht freies WLAN und wenn da irgendwie
was weiß ich
Hotspots, Service, haste nicht gesehen äh irgendwie oder äh Telekom oder Vodafone oder irgendwas an dem WLAN dransteht, da ich da gar keinen Bock mehr. Ich will halt, dass.
Ich will halt einfach Internet haben. Und das ist äh auch für diesen Kaffeebetreiber ich meine, der hat ja auch eine Toilette. Also muss der auch Internet haben
Und äh auch bei der Toilette nimmt er den nicht irgendwie äh deinen deinen Ausweis, weil er Angst hat, dass du da irgendwie eine Bremsspur drin lässt oder so. Weißt du, das ist irgendwie,
total daneben so. Okay.
Ähm der Kor. Hoffen wir auf den OGH.
Dann erzähl doch mal noch ein bisschen was über Edri.
Ja, ich habe ähm.
Noch eine wichtige Sache. Und zwar ähm wie gesagt, die Idee Generalversammlung ähm ist äh jetzt gerade in Berlin und ähm da haben wir uns auch wieder mal die Budgetzahlen angesehen und ähm äh sieht nicht so gut aus.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, was Edri ist. Wir haben es schon öfter erwähnt, aber.
Ach, das muss man kennen. Also Edri, European, Digital Rights ist,
Dachverband von einunddreißig netzpolitischen NGOs aus ganz Europa und sogar auch ein paar aus den USA, wie IFF. Da ist der CDC dabei, die Diggiges, die Digital Courage
und eigentlich aus allen großen aller großen und kleinen, netzpolitischen Organisationen in Europa. Also wirklich von denen, die
Angestellte haben bis zu den ehrenamtlichen Freiwilligen Vereinen, die es halt seit vielen Jahren gibt. Ähm, es ist wirklich die ganze Bandbreite und was Idri äh tut
ist genau diese äh Interessen ähm in Brüssel gegenüber den europäischen Institutionen zu vertreten.
Die kümmern sich um eure Kund und Menschen und Freiheitsrechte ähm gegenüber dem Europaparlament, der Kommission und dem Rat
und machen halt enorm viel, wenn's darum geht, äh auf diesem Kontinent irgendwie progressive Digitalpolitik zu bekommen, äh gerade eben dort, wo im Moment die meisten Gesetze gemacht werden und das ist eben,
inzwischen viel mehr Brüssel als die nationalen Hauptstädte. Und Edri macht 'n wahnsinnig tollen Job, ähm, das Büro dort.
Ich durfte ja selber mal ein paar Monate dort arbeiten, äh die äh haben wirklich, wirklich enorm viel drauf, also wenn's drum geht ähm,
diese Themen sauber zu argumentieren, äh gibt's niemanden, ich ich habe selber so viel gelernt in Sachen Atworcesy und wie man gutes Lobbing macht, dass ich dort war, ja. Und äh davon profitieren wir alle, deswegen gibt es Edria auch.
Und äh im Moment sieht's leider so aus, dass ähm diese wichtige Organisation noch nicht genügend Geld hat, um.
Für den Rest des Jahres wirklich alle Gehälter zu zahlen.
Im Worst Case Szenario sieht's wirklich schlimm aus. Es ist nun nicht lebensbedrohlich, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall ein ich sage mal,
gesund schrumpfen, was dann passieren müsste und das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was wir brauchen. Weil wir brauchen Expansion in dem Bereich, die Leute dort äh die drei, die Policy machen, äh
arbeiten wirklich enorm viel. Also äh nicht da irgendwie um zehn Uhr E-Mails und schicke wegen Netzautralität, kriege ich inzwischen schon Antworten. Also die Leut.
Sind schon am Anschlag und man müsste dort eigentlich ausbauen anstatt äh Ressourcen wegzunehmen.
Wenn's Edri Morgen nicht mehr geben würde, dann hätten wir nicht nur keine Stimme mehr in Brüssel.
Gar keine. Das ist ja das, das ist auch die einzige äh Organisation, die ja im Prinzip dieses Digital Rights Ding macht, oder? Also gibt es, gibt es noch, haben den Konkurrenten?
Es es gibt, es gibt äh äh Excess Access Now Europe, also die die Kollegen von Access Now.
Die sind auch vor Ort.
Die sind auch vor Ort, aber ich meine äh ähm die die haben die haben zwei Leute dort und äh das sind demselben Büro, das ist eine starke
Kooperation, also die beiden haben enorm viel Synergien und äh auch die äh sind natürlich voll alarmiert, weil die machen zum Beispiel auch kein Urheberrecht, die haben einzelne Themen, Netzneutralität,
zu ihrer zwei großen Städtenpferde,
da äh die werden auch total überfordert, wenn sie jetzt alleine all das machen müssen, weil gerade weil diese beiden Büros äh sich die Räume teilen und und gemeinsam an einem Strang ziehen,
kann man dort was erreichen und äh es ist nicht nur so, dass wir dann keine Stimme mehr hätten in Europa, sondern wir werden auch noch blind. Und taub
also blind und auch eine PR Lust, weil wir, weil wir ganz viel auch nicht mitbekommen, ein wichtiger Punkt, den Etry macht, ist ja gerade das Monitoring. Ähm, was jetzt gerade im Gesetzgebungsprozess äh an an Dossiers hochkommt und äh wo wir unsere Aufmerksamkeit drauf lenken müssen.
Und gerade diese Streaming-Prozess wird auch von niemand anderen gemacht, niemand ist so nah dran an den Institutionen und.
Die Realität ist einfach, wenn Idri heute ähm Bankrott gehen würde, müssen wir es morgen wieder neu gründen. Da führt kein Weg dran vorbei. Ähm
Deswegen hat Idria auch seit einigen Jahren jetzt eben neben äh Geld aus Förderungen und Stiftungen
auch noch eine normale Crowdfunding Schiene aufgemacht, wo sie eben um Spenden bitten, vor allem um Fördermitglieder und ich kann das nur allen ans Herz legen. Ähm, bei Etri Supporter zu werden und dort ähm ein paar Euro
im Monat oder Quartal oder Jahr einzukippen und äh denen die Arbeit zu erleichtern. Wir haben jetzt gerade äh ein ein
Kommissar Juncker, der Netzpolitik in seiner Antrittsrede als erstes Thema genannt hat. Gleichzeitig haben wir einen Öttinger, der wirklich riskiert
enorm viel Schaden anzurichten. Das ist jetzt der Punkt und und äh die fünf Jahre Legislaturperiode, in der wir ganz viele Plöcke einschlagen müssen. Und äh dafür brauchen wir Idri und deswegen ähm.
Mein Aufruf dieser tollen Organisation zu ermöglichen, zu wachsen. Anstatt zu schrumpfen.
Alles klar. Wir verlinken direkt die Spendenseite. Es gibt einfache Möglichkeiten hier ein Sepa-Mandat äh bereitzustellen und dann.
Müssen wir hoffen.
Abgeht. Ähm also Idri ist wirklich ja wichtig vor allem weil wir jetzt halt gerade also was da noch mit reinspielt ist dass wir im Prinzip nirgendwo mehr ähm.
Immer mehr von diesen netzpolitischen Dingen, die halt wirklich tragweite haben,
werden halt in Brüssel entschieden und da sitzen wir hier, ne? In irgendwie in Berlin oder Wien und so. Wir kümmern uns auch immer um unsere, um unseren lokalen Scheiß, aber wir müssen eben auch immer öfter
auf EU-Ebene klagen. Wir müssen auf müssen EU-Gesetzgebung irgendwie bekämpfen. Die gesamte Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgeschichte,
ist über Jahre durch diese durch diese Brüsselnummer ähm verargumentiert worden in Deutschland zumindest. Ja, bis wird so, dass ähm.
Da geht's halt ab und da irgendwie, dass wir da irgendwie nur mit ein paar Leuten sitzen, das kann kein dauerhafter Zustand sein.
Insofern ähm bitte dort das Geld hin.
Ähm gut, das das war's zum äh Emergency Spendenaufruf.
Und was ich zuletzt noch zu vermelden habe äh äh wieder ein Österreich Spezifikum ähm Habemus, CC äh nach
zehn Jahren Pause gibt es jetzt wieder einen aktiven Erfurter Kreis äh des CC in Österreich, der,
die C drei W, äh, der CC in Wien hat sich neu gegründet, äh, nachdem er zweitausendsechs eingeschlafen ist, als das Mieterlab der Hacker
gegründet wurde und äh die beschäftigen sich gerade recht viel mit der Discal Road,
so einer Partizilationssimulation unserer Regierung und ähm das sind jetzt äh war die Generalversammlung und die,
Leute die da gewählt wurden, ähm, haben ein vollstes Vertrauen, das sieht so aus, wenn wir hier wirklich wieder ein,
tiefen CC in Österreich bekommen. Ähm und das äh stimmt mich voller Hoffnung und äh ist auch gerade äh
noch rechtzeitig vor dem Easterheck, was auch Qualität in Salzburg stattfinden wird. Äh Tickets dazu sind schon längst ausverkauft, also.
Ist vorbei. Das äh äh war, da müsste man dann auch nochmal drüber reden, ob das äh
gut, ob das gut dimensioniert ist von der Location her, da äh ist halt du, ich kenne eine ganze Menge Leute, die sehr äh traurig sind, ähm da nicht mehr hinzukönnen
ich hab gehört zum Glück nicht dazu und werde selbstverständlich beim Easterhack sein, aber das äh heißt, das ist aber im Prinzip das Metallab.
Also das Metallleib hat sich jetzt wieder dem.
Nein nein, es ist es ist sozusagen eine, dass das Medialab versteht sich ja nur als Infrastruktur und als neutrale Plattform für alles mögliche. Du kannst da irgendwie äh Tor entwickeln oder dort,
äh und äh die auch eben politische ähm Gruppen und Aktivitäten sind dort gern gesehen und da.
Weit ein für das Metallab ist ein Ort. Und keine äh.
Genau, hat keine Meinung. Äh mein, sagen sie immer und äh eben der CC hat sich dort jetzt mal neu gegründet, aber äh im Moment äh verlinkt C3W Punkt AT auch noch auf die,
mit der Lab Wiki Seite, das wird sich bald ändern und man arbeitet daran, dass dann sozusagen auch als eigenes Ding sichtbar rauszulösen. Aber es ist natürlich äh, wenn es sich physisch trifft, wird es dort im Hackerspace sein
Ähm und es soll aber eben halt auch wieder diese Spaß am Gerät Hacking, äh Netzpolitik äh Aspekte damit in Österreich auch wieder aus der,
Ecke beleuchten und das finde ich sehr gut.
Das ist gut, ja. Das ist sehr gut. Da freuen wir uns.
Ähm ja, Erfahrs gründen, das ist sowieso äh was, was man mal machen kann.
Oder dem äh lokalen Erfahren beitreten der CCC äh heißt immer Besucher auf seine liebeswirtschamante Art willkommen.
Alle Aliens dürfen vorbeikommen.
An bestimmten Tagen zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit, wenn sie keine doofen Fragen stellen. Nein. Nein, in der Tat.
Gibt es im CC gerade äh an in mehreren Airfas echt auch wieder,
neue, coole Entwicklungen eben zu der äh zu der Offenheit. Ja, ich meine natürlich suchen die Leute auch irgendwie
in ihrem Freundeskreis mit ihren Leuten, in ihrem Zufluchtsort äh eben auch eine Privatheit, die äh an der halt das,
Das Türschloss des der Mitgliedschaft äh
klemmt so, das ist halt normal, sie machen das Vereine halt und äh dafür baut man sich ja auch Hackerspaces, damit es halt ein Hackerspace ist, ne? Aber ähm so in mehreren Städten gibt's halt richtig geile ähm Entwicklungen
quasi diese Tage der offenen Tür auch wieder,
weniger, jetzt da könnt ihr mal reingucken, sondern so richtige wir bieten etwas
sind, ne? Da gibt's dann irgendwie Open Chaos und solche Geschichten, wo dann halt Leute äh spezifisch eingeladen werden oder
wo es ein Angebot gibt, ne? Da kommst du halt nicht rein und sagst, ah, jetzt kann ich mal sehen, wie das bei euch aussieht. Äh sondern ähm.
Man äh kommt hin und kriegt was geboten.
Ähm und das ist net, das ist schon ganz äh ganz coole Entwicklung, die es da so an äh vielen,
ähm in vielen Bereichen gibt. Hamburg tut sich da. Insbesondere vor Berlin hat glaube ich jetzt auch äh,
zwei äh offene Tage quasi die Woche und so und da kann man äh sich den den Häckern nähern.
Open Chaos, finde ich einen schönen Namen.
Und äh ja ist ganz cool, ne?
Ja? Äh wir wir haben ja auch alle einen Bildungsauftrag.
Und in Hamburg glaube ich sogar jetzt blöd jetzt. Die machen glaube ich auch mehr äh ja genau. Junghackertag. Ich glaube einmal im Monat haben die.
Jungen Hacker-Tag oder die bemühen sich so, das ist dann auch immer angekündigt. Ähm.
Und da haben sie dann halt auch eine für die für die Jungen irgendwie für die jungen Leute halt coole Ideen. Ja, Oktober war einer.
Dezember, also so, ja, ne, wir sind ja alles Ehrenamtliche und das ist schon ganz, ganz geil alles.
Ja, ich finde das gut. Also das äh ist ja auch langfristig der einzige Weg, wie man diese Themen äh in der Gesellschaft verankert, in dem äh,
öffnet und zeigt so ähm.
Diese ganze Technik, die euch ansonsten vielleicht überrollt, da kann man auch irgendwie mit einem spielerischen Zugang drauf zugehen und äh gerade eben für für junge Leute, glaube ich, dass das Programm, was der CC fährt, ähm
genau der richtige Ansatz ist um ähm dann am Ende auch die Politischen Kämpfe äh zu gewinnen. Also ich hasse das zwar, weil die Leute sagen am Ende ist alles
ein Bildungsproblem, aber aber langfristig stimmt das natürlich.
Ja und das ist also das ist für die natürlich wollen wir da die Leute äh zu ordentlichen strammen Freiheitskämpfern erziehen.
Das ist nichts, ne? Aber zwischendurch wollen wir auch vor allem einfach mal Spaß am Gerät haben.
So Thomas, jetzt schmeiße ich dich raus. Das war, jetzt musst du zurück zu Edri.
Ich spende in der Zeit ein bisschen, versuche mal hier eine die Sendung zu schneidern
und danke dir sehr für dein Kommen und wünsche dir vor allem enormen Erfolg in Sachen Safety Internet und Berek.
Vielen Dank und bis zum nächsten Mal. Ciao, ciao. Tschüss.
Ciao ciao. Tschüss.